Codelabs
(Stands by)
(Standing by)
» (Standing by).
Building apps
for the Google Assistant.
(Standing by)
amp theater
amphitheater
Sundar
.
» Well, good morning and welcome
(Applause).
» You know, whenever I give a
talk at I/O     I/O I always ask
to be first thing in the
morning because I know only the
most motivated smartest best
looking audience comes.  Give
yourselves a round of applause
for     for being here.
(Applause).
» So we are going to talk about
building apps for the Google
Assistant.  If you know nothing
about building apps for the
Google Assistant you're in the
right place.  This is meant to
be an orientation talk, to give
you a sense for what scenarios
work, how to accomplish it.
Hopefully at the end of this
talk we will intrigue you to
want to drill in more and find
out more formation.  I'm Brad
Abrams.  I'm the product manager
on the Google Assistant team.
I'm Vera Tzoneva
.   .
» VERA TZONEVA:  I'm Vera
Tzoneva.
» ADAM COIMBA:  I'm Adam Coimba.
» When Sundar launched it it was
to provide an interface for all
Google regardless of what
device you're in or what task
you're trying to accomplish.
The way we think about the
Assistant it's a conversation
between you and Google designed
to help you get things done in
your world.  And one of the
reasons I'm personally so
excited about the Assistant is
it builds s on blg        s on
Google's long history of
creating ecosystems.  History
started with Google search where
we created a strong ecosystem
between publishers s and reader
s.  It continues s with      s
with      s with YouTube where
we have a strong ecosystem
between creators s and their
viewers   ers.  Many of you know
on Play we created an ecosystem
between Android app developers
ers and their use     users.
It's that same system that we
are creating with Google
Assistant.  And that's by action
actions s on Google.
You may be interested on actions
s on Google because it enables
s you to connect with a whole
set of users in different
contexts s and different places
everywhere the Google Assistant
is.  You can it is
You can also connect new and
existing users.  And it GI us
it gives you an
opportunity to innovate this
domain of conversational
interface which we will talk
more about in this talk.  So
since we launched the platform
in December          December we
couldn't          couldn't be
more happy with the variety and
creativity of apps for the
Assistant that we have seen,
whether you want to order a Piza
a pizza from dominos
domino's, you can do a
wide variety of activities.  I
want to drill in on one
particular today to give you the
anatomy of one     one of these
Assistant apps.  How do they
work, what is really under the
covers s.  So some of you may
have noticed in addition to the
Android version of the Google
I/O     I/O app we now have a
Google Assistant I/O     I/O app
as well.  So you're able
to talk to your Assistant and
say okay Google talk to I/O
to I/O 17, and the
Assistant looks at all the ways
it could possibly respond, all
the context, all the possible
different options, and picks the
very best one for this user at
this time.  In this case because
the user used the app name.
»           name explicitly, I/O
I/O 17, then that's like a
URL or    or tapping on a
shortcut on the desk top.  And
it brings us directly in to our
Google I/O     I/O 17 app.  The
user          The user hears s
the s       s the Assistant give
an introduction and     and
hearse            and here's
here's an ear con.  It's a
visual audio distinction to help
the users understand there's a
transition happening.  And
there's a change in the voice
and the icons s change.  Now
there's a two-way dialogue
between the Google I/O     I/O
app and the user.  And that
two-way dialogue continues until
either party is ready to exit.
That's how it looks on Google
home.  We were launching for
phones here at the event so we
wanted to make it work well on
the phone.  There you see it
working on the phones.  Suggest
chips.                   .
Suggestion chips and images s
and what not.  In addition to
that we also wanted to let you
book      book seats s.  Some of
you may have noticed the
sessions yesterday were kind of
full.  You can increase
You can
reserve seats to the sessions.
We wanted to           wanted to
let you do that transaction as
well to book a seat so when a
session comes up you can reserve
a seat.  If you click that we
use our     our seem less
seamless account
linking.  With just two taps you
can create an a opportunity.
Then you see your receipt and
it's free to reserve a seat.
And the transaction is complete.
So actually what we are going
to do is walk through the end to
end experience of building that
app I just showed you in this
suggestion.  I'm going to start
off by talking about the design
process, how did we come up with
that app, what was the design
that went      went into it.
Adam is going to go through the
hard core development of it,
both the natural language
understanding part as well as
the transactionat part and
as the transactional part and
show you in code how to build
that.  Ver     Vera is going to
show you how to make that app
app discoverable, how to
use that app.  Let's drill into
design.
First do we need design at all?
I mean these conversational
apps, these       these
Assistant appears         apps
they're just chat box, right?
It's text input, text output,
there's no            there's no
images s, no forms.  Do you
need design at all?  Well,
consider a very simple case.
Say we wanted to reserve a
number of seats, a number of
seats at a restaurant.  How
might we handle this case?  We
say     say for how many, look
at the wide variety of ways that
a user might respond to this
query.  How are we supposed to
supposed to handle
each one of these cases?  Well
the answer of course is in the
design            the design.
But what is the nature of design
for these           for these
Assistant apps?
Well, or    oren Jacob coined
this phrase interactive screen
writing which is what we are
trying to build with these
Assistant apps.  When you build
an Assistant app it's kind of
like writing a screen play for a
movie or TV show where you're
writing dialogue except you get
to write lines 1, 3, 5 and 7,
and somebody you have no control
over gets to write lines 2, 4,
6 and 8.  And you have to use
that to come together with a
beautiful experience.  To do
that you have to pull together
design elements s from two
different disciplines.  One is
the Lin Knar Marashian
is
the linear narrative design.
That's where we learn about
learn about character
, storytelling, dialogue from
books s, TV shows and movies.
We have to merge that with what
we learned from interactive
design, what we get there grams
get from Gambs
from games and
and mobile web app design.  So
we need to bring those things
together.  So let's          So
let's talk about how we do that
here.  We looked at all of our
Assistant apps and found out the
element that they had in
common, the     , the ones that
got the most re    retentions,
they had a strong persona so we
wanted to           wanted to
build that for our app.  So what
we did is we actually thought
about you, what would you want
out of the app.  We benefitted
from having the marketing team
that we could work with but you
don't need a marketing team.
And really sat down and
understood the brand attributes
s and the design principals s.
And from that we distilled the
style guide.  And this style
guide helped us write the
dialogue for our Assistant app.
There are actually several of
us writing dialogue.  By
actually having a guide like
this, I literally had a version
of this that we kept up while we
were writing dialogue.  It kept
the persona tight and crisp
even though different people
were writing.
So just to tell you, we also
wanted to launch for the phone
so we knew we wanted both visual
and eyes-free experience.  And
so we wanted to make sure we had
the similar content.  So one
Assistant           Assistant
but similar content so the chat
bubbles are a subset of the
spoken text.  And that's because
we could use suggestion chips
which we just fell in love with
as an easy way to navigate
through your Assistant app.
User Darwinian have
User didn't have
to guess at what our app could
do.  We could put the most
prominent things there and users
could sift through kwekly.
through quickly.
We also found a visual
description really helped bring
more life.
So while that was a whirl wind
tour of design for
conversational apps, there's way
more to be said about it.  I
hope you'll take an opportunity
to drill into more of the
sessions here at I/O     I/O or
catch       catch them on
YouTube after.  Adam is going to
talk about building these
things.  Adam.
» BRAD ABRAMS:
.
» ADAM COIMBA:  Thanks, brat.  I
work               , Brad.   .
Our mission is to help develop
ers   ers and partners s like
you launch on the ace
on the Shutterstock
on the
Assistant.  I couldn't
I couldn't be more
excited to show some of these
awesome new features that we are
launching   ing.  A couple
slides back Brad showed some
really good screen shots of this
Assistant app for Google I/O
I/O that let you reserve a
seat and sign in.  Today I'm
going to try to build it with
you right now.
So let's
So let's look at some of the
steps that we tubing
we took to do that and you can
try yourself.  First       First
wee     we create a project on
the actions s console.  We then
connect a natural language tool
like API,      API AI.  If you
have your own tool you can
connect that right to our API
API.
We then connect a web book.
Again we like noticed
noticed              like node
detective          JK but
JS but you can use any.  In the
actions s console you can try it
on on your Google home, (audio
fading in and out) or
,
Android or iPhone.
We
Finally we enable that seamless
sign in flow and the ordering
experience by integrateing with
the transactions API.  Once we
have all this done how does it
happen that a user can saying
snog the Assistant
can saying
something to the Assistant and
it triggers the     s the app?
The user says something like
that you can              that
you can to Google I/O     I/O 17
to their enabled d device like
Google.  It's streamed through
and transcribed d as text.  The
Assistant uses the user as
context                     the
user's con tekd           's
context to understand that oip
app              that I/O
I/O app is the right service for
that request.  The API agent
understands an intent to defined
there that you defined.  It
then calls the web book to talk
to the I/O            to the I/O
API and get some data.  And
formulates s a conversational
response which is sent all the
way back through to API AI to
the sis sus                   AI
to the Assistant and     and
out to the users.  We mentioned
that the actions s console is
like the starting point.  We are
excited about this.  We
launched it yesterday.  It's a
really focused way to develop
and manage your Assistant app.
The three main things it does is
one allowing to configure
to configure and
set up the            set up the
metadata.   .  It then allows s
you to manage the testing and
deployment process in a fine
grained way.  Once live it
givers you analytics s so you
can track how it's doing in the
weerl           the real world
with the real user s.      s.
Then we connect
to API AI or other tools.   .
We define intents s and entities
.  We can understand
can understand in
a structured d way tw        d
way what the user wants.
Entities are structured d pacts
s have text that let
d packets of
text.  Once we have these deep
find we                    these
defined we can write responses
to user requests.  Now that we
have our basic model set up we
can use training in API AI to
improve the dialogue over time f
the user were to say what
Android sessions there are, API
AI is going to list that
incident and it's going to send
a request down to the web hook
and trigger a function there.
Let's look at the web hook.  Now
you can build a web hook using
any web server framework.  We
like node JS.  You can get that
with one command, and basically
we have a bit of boiler plate
and we have a handler for this
list session         session
intent, list topics s incident.
We are getting a structured d
set of categories and
formulating a conversational
response.  The topics s covered
are dot, do.       , dot, dot.
Frf      .
Now we went to test this ut
this out.  We have a sim
plateor               a
simulator.  It's super important
to test on device.  Just by
clicking test on actions s
console you can take your device
and say talk to my app and
you're going to be able to test
it out just like that.
So I'm going to go over to my
demo one machine and we are
going to try this out with the
real I/O     I/O app.
.  We can see it's already set
up with the I/O         the I/O
demo app.  We have some app
information set up there.  Which
is basically branding
information.  And it's already
connect         connected to an
API AI project.  And we have
some intents s set up.  We have
a welcome incident which handles
s the case where it triggers s
the app.  We have the choose
session intent which let's the
user get details about a session
and a couple others.  I've been
around I/O     I/O yesterday
and     and heard some develop
ers   ers wondering what the
free stuff was this year.  Why
don't we make this app useful
saying what is the swag at I/O
I/O and get a useful
response.  We will create an
intent, call it s      it the
swag intent and add a query,
what is the swag at I/O     I/O.
We can find a response with
the tool.  It's Google home.
And $700 in cloud credits s.
Awesome.  And so we just hit
save.  We go to the actions s on
Google integration.  And we
click test.  Just like that we
can try this out in our web
simulator.
So we say talk to I/O        to
I/O demo.  Then we have of to
log in                   have to
log in.  It    It invokes this
app and we    we can say what is
the Zwag          the swag at
I/O     I/O?  And it's a Google
home and 700 in cloud credits s.
Now that we have some of the
wafshg            the basic
wirings s set up we can talk
about making this work really
nicely on mobile.  So back here
.  So to make it work really
nicely on mobile we want to add
visual responses with API to AI
and with our web hook.  API AI
provides build in card building
interfails.  And this is really
nice, it let's us easily define
cards and chips and car sells
carosouls and lists.  You can
create dynamic responses.  So
that's a really nice useful
feature we have added.
Let's look at how we do fwrit
do it from the web
hooks.  There's two important
things.  The first is we are
checking whether the user has a
screen.  We need to be aware of
the user's modality and
tailor accordingly.  We show a
rich card populated with data
about the session.  Now I can
head back over to the machine
and show adding that right into
the I/O         the I/O app.
Heading back over the the demo
one machine, great.  Okay.  So
we have this session that this
intent that handles s the moment
when the user has asked for
information specific information
about a session.  So this is
the choose session intent.  And
what we can do is add suggestion
chips right there with the API
to AI response builder.  So we
add some suggestion chips and
add that reserve a seat chip.
We can add some others like next
session, other topics s, and
hit save.  Now to add that rich
card that's dynamically
populated we need to turn over
to the web book and
to the web hook and
update it.  This is the web hook
code.  We have a controller for
our app.  It has a pointer that
that triggers s a function
in the noticed             the
node JS code.  It's doing a
simple thing, calling to I/O
to I/O API and creating a
simple text response.  So we
have that woed           that
code that we showed before
prepared here and we can add it
in and we are checking whether
there's streen output,
whether the user has a screen.
If they do then we add this
rich response.  Otherwise we can
fall back on this text response
.  And my web hook will
automatically update and I can
go and update
.  And test.  Now we are head
can back               heading
back to the simulator.
And let's say I'm interested in
the what's new in Android
session.  So I'll get this rich
card with a link and with
suggest chips.  That was pretty
easy, right?  Okay.  So the last
part then heading back into the
deck is to add this transaction
al experience where the user can
sign in and they can actually
make an order.  So we are so
excited about the transactions
API.  It released for developer
pre      er preview yesterday.
It let's you except purchases
and orders from your users with
your app.  We make this great
experience on the Assistant with
first providing a seamless
building experience between the
user and the app.  Once the user
has this information and
and approved d the purchase we
give you a way to reengage.  We
can send          can send
updates to the receipt.  You can
reengage and get the user back
into your app that way.  To
integrate with the transactions
API there are five steps.  First
building out a basket and
shopping cart.  This can be as
simple as a suggestion chip or
complicated as a menu ordering
experience with lots of choices
and     and customizations s.
You might need for information
about the user like their
delivery address so we give you
an API to request that.  Once
your order is all set up you
need to propose to it the user
and get their authorization so
we provide a propose order API
that let's the user preview what
you're asking them to buy and
approve it.  Once they have
approved it you need to confirm
the order.  Let them know it's
active and provide a receipt.
Lastly many transactional
experiences require the user's
identity.  We provide the
ability to integrate with a web
server and provide a seamless
log in flow for the user.
Let's take a deeper look into
that.  So many of you hopefully
are familiar
with it, it's pretty standard.
You can figure the usual off
two stuff there.  And that let's
us know how to talk to your
server.  And then in dialogue
you call an API to trigger the
sign in flow.  So you can do
that from API
.AI      API.AI or to the web
hook.  We are building a
structure d   d ordered
We are building a structured
ordered object and
object.  Once the order has been
pro     proposed we get a new
request saying the user excepted
the              excepted the
order,
the user accepted the or
the order, now you need
to confirm it.  We say the
status is con tirmd
confirmed, we provide a receipt
and sent          and send it to
the user just like any other
visual response.  One more time
going back to the machine and we
are going to add this into our
app.
he had           we    we had
this suggestion chip.  We can
create the reserve a seat intent
and it will be         will be
triggered when if user
when the user says reserve
a seat.  We want to immediately
call the sign in API.  So
there's            So there's a
little bit of code we    we need
to put in to API.AI to trigger
that and we can trigger that and
add it here and hit save.  With
that we are calling the sign in
POI POI            in API.AI to
log in the user.  We    We
.  Going back into the console
we can see what we did.  We have
this account linking session.
We can edit it.  There's a
couple extra steps that we take
in our server to make the
integration seem less and it's
easy to do and we highly
recommend everyone does it.  We
have an intent to handle when
the user says reserve a seat.
What happens when if
when the user signs in?  We have
this intent that passes that
event through to our webhook.
We are then going to call the
proposed order API.  Once the
order is proposed we get another
request to API.AI saying the
user          the user accepts
s, you have to confirm the order
.  That is here.  That's passed
through to the webhook and then
we are done.  The last thing is
to add this code into our
webhook.  We see we have the
controller for our app and we
have the handle sign in and hand
handle order handlers s.
We see they're empty right now
so we can add in that code.
look familiar, we are building
an order object, proposing it to
the user with this call right
here.  For handle decision this
is where the user has already
accepted the
accepted the order and we want
to provide a receipt.  So we can
add that code.  And it should
automatically update.  So that's
it.  That's all it took.  Now
we can test this out on my demo
two device.
Just have to update the project
.  Cool.  So we are going to go
over to the demo two device and
we can say I/O     I/O demo.
What is new in Android?
We can tap the reserve a seat
chip.
er preview.  (Laughter).
We can do one thing and I think
it will make it work.  Thank you
.  Thank you           Thank
you.
(Applause).
» We appreciate it.  So I think
it will work if I can just do
this.  Might have been user
error.  (Laughter).
Okay.  So let's          So
let's try one more time.  I/O
I/O demo.
What's new in Android?
Hmm.  There we
go.  Cool.
And we see with just two taps
I'm creating an account on this
server.  And we proposed the
proposed the order
to the user, what's
what's new in Android, zero
dollars, I approve.  And we get
our receipt.  Cool.  So that's
all it took.  We did that in
like ten minutes prch (applause)
ten
minutes.
(Applause).
A transition
A transactional experience.  Let
me do a quick recap on what we
did.
So we created a rich model
experience
a rich mobile experience
for finding out about I/O
I/O sessions.  We added a chip
to let the user reserve a chip
and we used the transactions API
to pro        to propose if
reservation and get the user
the user's acceptance
and get a seat.  I believe all
of you     you can build apps
right now and I'm excited to
I'm excited to
see what you do.  With that I'm
going to hand it over to Vera.
» VERA TZONEVA:  Thank you.
Thanks, Adam.  I'm Vera and I'm
here to tell you how your app
can be discovered once you build
.  I have the opportunity to
talk to partners s like you
every day and this is one of the
of the primary things
that we hear.  Let's actually
start by admitting that we live
in a pretty amazing time in
technology.  People are asking
computers to do things for them.
They are asking them to help
them plan their day, to get from
one place to another and to
even clean their apartment in a
mess.  And they're asking for
the little things like my little
brother despite being 22
recently          recently asked
the Google Assistant how to
make scrambled eggs for our pam
for our family.  We
know that if you're building a
productivity app or a recipe app
or smart home app your users
are out there looking for you.
And if there's one thing that we
learned about discovery over
the years is that the best way
to find users who want your
service is for them to find you.
actual little a very different
world.  No longer does the user
have to know that your app
exists or have to download it or
even have to set it up.  All
they have to do is say okay
Google or long press on home on
their mobile skwis
mobile device and they have
access to your service and
that's on over 100 million plus
devices s.
And I'll be honest, we are still
getting started.  There's a ton
of work to do.  But that's a
pretty exciting thing.  Our goal
at Google is to help connect
you to your users.  Today we are
starting with three primary
ways of enables         enabling
discovery of the Google app
through your Assistant.  The
first is through dial leg so
directly in conversation with
the user.  The he could he could
The
second is through the siscy  cy
director.
the Assistant directory, and the
third is through links you can
share.  First we will start with
dialogue.  The most reliable
way that a user can get to your
Assistant app is by explicitly
asking for it, meaning we have a
set of pre-established phrases,
things like talk to, speak to,
to, that one said with the
name of your Assistant app we
introduce you and you own the
dialogue end to end.  A user can
also deep link directly to an
answer so to extend a demo that
Adam just did a user can say hey
Google let's talk to I/O
to I/O 17           to I/O 17
and we introduce the app.  It
can also say something like hey
Google ask I/O     I/O 17 about
about what was announced
and we can take you to the
answer.  Some examples are let's
speak to dominos and we
introduce           introduce
dominos and     and dominos
comes
Domino's
and we introduce Domino's and
Domino's comes in.  Or hey
Google and            Google
akinateor
Akinator
Akinator or hey ask Dr. Doggie
if dogs can eat chocolate.  It's
very similar to typing a URL
and getting to a website or
tapping on an app icon and going
inside the            inside
the app.
The next way to introduce your
Assistant app in dialogue is
through implesmt
implicit triggering.  I'm
excited about this because it
starts showing the promise of
the platform.  We know that
users are asking the Google
Assistant a whole set of things.
They're asking hey tell me a
joke or I want to play a game or
I want to work out.  And we at
Google through
Google look at    at all the
apps that can fulfill on that
and suggest them to the users.
This already works today.  You
can say hey Google I want to
work out and we introduce fit
star which has a great guided
work out.  All you have to do is
add an invocation grammar to
your app in API.AI or whatever
natural language solution that
you use.  I want to show you
what that looks like because
it's super easy.
If we go to the demo one device.
Maybe?  Ms.      ?
Can we go to the demo one
device, the computer, please?
If not maybe we will pause for a
second.  Here we are.  Awesome.
We are here in the swag intent
that Adam created and you can
see his what's        what's the
swag at I/O     I/O.  Let's say
you want to add something more
colloquial like what is the
freebie at I/O     I/O?  Type it
in.  You can scroll down, the
answer is still the same.  You
guys got a home and 700 in cloud
credits s, it's awesome.  Make
sure the conversation you save
and that's really it.  You're
able to test it by going to
integrations s, actions s on
Google.  Make sure you select
the swag intent here.  And then
once you hit test, that's it.
So let's go to the demo two
device and try it out.  So in
this
case Adam      Adam what is
your... what is your password?
(Laughter).
What is it
?  You're logged in?  Do you
want to unlock it?  We can do
the test later but basically
what happens is you say what is
the freebie at I/O     I/O and
we introduce the Google I/O
I/O 17 app.  Let's say you never
heard of it before.  And then
the Google I/O     I/O 17 app is
able to say your freebie at I/O
I/O is the Google home and
1700 dlardz                 and
$700 in app credits s.  One of
the primary questions that we
get about implicit triggering is
how are you     you goes going
to ring.  We are looking at a
ton of different signals s.  One
of the primary things we are
going to look at is the quality
of your app as well as things
like      like the user
the user's context or
preferences s.  And we will
experiment significantly over
time.
The next way for you to grow
discovery of your Assistant app
is through the Assistant
director.  We launched this with
the goal of letting a user try
We launched this with the goal
of letting a user try out new
apps, browse apps.  The way that
a user gets to the Assistant
director on Android is by long
pressing on home and tapping the
upper right and corner icon.
On iOS they get there by going
to the Assistant app and same
thing, , tapping on the upper
right corner icon and there's
also a web link for the
directory.  They can scroll
different categories, they can
try the app, they can rate the
app.  And then they can also set
their own personal preferences
s with the app.  We have this
concept of voice shortcuts.
This is where a user can go
directly to your Assistant app.
.  Mine says hey Google it's
chill out time and then Netflix
starts playing on my chrome cast
.   .  I have one another
another that
another that says
it's party time and can't touch
this starts playing on my home
device on Spotify.  The way that
you can improve visibility of
your app within the directory is
by again keep the quality of
your app really, really high.
This is what is going to help
with ranking and reviews s.  And
then two, submit which images
s, well written descriptions s,
this is going to encourage the
user to try out the app and re
engage with it again in the
future.
and grow awareness of your
Assistant app.  We engorge you
encourage to you do
this by sharing through social
media, encourage your user
s to take this.  Promote through
your own site or apps.
Encourage users to use your
service across different
platforms s.  And then three,
encourage press to drive traffic
to your Assistant app.  Allow
other sites to link to it.
Enable awareness that way.
Let's go to device three and I
can show you what it looks like
as well
.  You tap on the upper
right-hand corner, we scroll
down to education refugees
reasons, talk
to education
reference.  You can hit share.
.  Let's actually tweet it.
This is live.  Which is awesome.
You can say we are live at I/O
I/O.
And actually tweet it.  Once a
user taps on that link they go
directly to your landing page
within the directory.  Awe
soment.               Awesome.
Go back to the slides, please.
can grow discovery of your
Assistant app is one, in
dialogue.  So directly in the
conversation with the user both
implicitly and explicitly.  Two
through the Assistant directory.
And three through links that
you share.  So we know if you're
ilg            you're building
a recipe app that helps you book
breakfast for your family or a
fitness app that helps someone
keep their routine
routine your use     users are
looking for you and our goal is
to help you connect with the
users.  With that      that I'll
hand it to Brad to wrap up.
(Applause).
» BRAD ABRAMS:  We showed you a
ton of stuff today, doing
transactions and getting your
app discovered.  You're now
ready to participate in our app
development challenges.  Tons of
great       great prizes s.
But let's keep this conversation
going.  We are going to be at
the Assistant both which is kind
of in the main area on the
walkway there.  Come by and talk
to us with more questions, ton
of other talks.  A special
thanks to sajit who if he
who helped us build
the appear.  So thank you.
.
(Applause).
(Session concluded).
.
May 18, 2017.     .
9:30 a.m.-                :17.
9:30 a.m.-10:30 a.m.
(Applause).
» Great to see you.  Thanks for
being here.  I like the people
in the second section getting an
update on VR and AR, and a good
suntan at the same time.
That's cool.  Good job.  So
hopefully you caught the news
yesterday.   .  A great momentup
with apps on daydream, more
daydream ready phones on the way
.  Stand alone headsets s.
Super precise indoor location
service, , and an update to sped
dations                to
expeditions s.  The people on
our team are leading many of the
projects you're going to be
hearing about today.  Before I
do that I wanted to
I wanted to put what we are
doing in VR and AR in Google at
context, kind of put some had of
some of the puzzle
pieces together so you can
understand what we are doing.
And as developers   ers what you
can expect from us.  If you
follow what we have been up to
over the past several years
you're        you're
years you've seen a
bunch of different pieces, VR
apps, we are working in VR,
doing work in AR.  What is going
on here?  How do you think
about this?
So first of all terminology.
Over the past year especially
I've seen so many debates about
VR versus AR, which is going to
win?  What vocab to use.  To us
these terms
don't represent two sprays
sprays and
two separate and distinct
things.  The spuk trem
The spectrum of
immersive computing
.  Virtual Reality, and     and
real reality is at the other end
of the spectrum.  There's not
specific labels s but this whole
spectrum and we are doing work
across it.  But why invest in
this?   ?  Why is it important?
VR, AR, immersive computing,
they enable us to experience
computing much like the real
world.  We think it's a big idea
and really important because
every time computers s have
started to            started to
work                 started to
work more like we do, good
things have happened.  If you
think about moving from punch
cards to the command line to the
gooey              to the guy
to the gooey to
touch screens
GUI to
touch screens and we think VR
and AR will push this even
further.  It anticipates
It opens access
to more information, information
that's ang core      core
that's anchored to
the real world.  In a time it's
going to change how we play and
live and learn.  We want to help
push this forward in two ways
ways.  First platforms s.
Just as Chrome made the web
faster, more secure
more secure, powerful, and as
Android made mobile computing
more available.  Our geel
Our goal is to raise
all by doing a lot of the heavy
lifting in the core system
software and SD    SDK's.
The second part is building
blocks.  I mean the enabling
technologies like tango, web VR,
code samples s and more
Tango,
web VR, code samples and more.
.  We also think of the apps
we built as building blocks.
They're examples of VR apps to
look at and learn from.  This
morning is about these two
things, platforms s and building
blocks.  With that I'd like to
turn it over to Johnny Lee, the
founder of the tanko project
of    of
the Tango project to talk about
one of our most important
building blocks.  Thanks.
(Applause).
» JOHNNY LEE:  Hi, everyone,
great to be here.  My name is
Johnny Lee.  I'm the engineering
director of Tango.   .  In 2013
a small group of us got
together with the belief that
one day our devices s were able
to sense 3D motion and space
just like we can.  So with the
right combination of hardware
and software, Tango can give our
devices s this 3D sense of
motion sensing capabilitys s as
well as the ability to recognize
places        places its been
before.  This establishes a
shared sense of space and
physical movement between people
and our sdwoiss s.  It allowed
us to begin creating experiences
that give us an early glimpse
of how we can interact with
a visual object in a physical
way
devices.
It allowed us to begin
creating experiences that give
us an early glimpse of how we
can interact with a visual
object in a physical way.  A
sense of 3D tracking is a
fundamental part of the user
experience.  Tango is involved
in technology that is everything
we are doing in daydream.
Yesterday           Yesterday
you heard Clay about about
support for stand alone headsets
Yesterday you heard Clay about
about support for stand alone
headsets.  We can enable a
headset with the user es head
without
the user's head without all the
cables s and we call this world
world
WorldSense
WorldSense.  There's two
wide angle cameras s that detect
the movement of    of features
in the room, it might be
might be the corners s of
the desk or items on the table.
And it tracks s the movement of
these features over time to get
the sense of its position in
the room.  We take this
information with the motion
sensors s on the phone
s on the phone to
provide robust low latency
tracking and do this         do
this in less      less than five
millisecond
-milliseconds s.  At the
same time the system is
building a 3D mobile of
model of the scene so it
can correct any drift that may
occur over time.  You may have
heard this referred to as slam
or simultaneous localization and
mapping
or simultaneous localization
and mapping.  Now in smartphone
AR, AR applications s require
sensing even more of the
environment.  To be able to
place visual objects in front of
us to seem as though they
physically exist.  Today Tango
phones use richer sensors s.  We
have a dedicated depth sensor
that allows games to understand
the difference between the floor
, the table and the walls s.
And even let's characters s hide
behind things like couches.  We
have a wide angle cram
angle camera that gives us
the best features of the room
and this improves s or ability
to quickly relocalious
relocalious letting you see SR
see AR con dent
AR content that was left
there before.  With all of this
technology put together I
wanted to             I wanted
to share with you this project
we have been dong      doing
with the Singapore arts science
museum.
We have audio for the video?  (
Music playing).
» Most people living in cities
have never been to a rain forest
.  We decided to bring a rain
forest to a city and make it
accessible for everyone.  For
that we needed a new Google
technology.  We were able to map
10,000 square feet of museum
space into a rain important
a rain forest.
This is the experience of what
it's like to walk through a ran
forest              a rain
forest
.  We are able to launch this
experience on the first Tango
enabled d device and bring AR at
scale to everyone making into
the wild the largest AR
experience in the world.
» JOHNNY LEE:  Sorry about
missing -- thanks.  (Applause).
thousands of visitors s to come
and experience a digital rain
forest.  When they pledge a
donation to the world wile
to the world
wildlife fund they are able to
plant a tree and it expands s
over time as visitors s see the
xhibt.              the exhibit.
We are still in the early days
s of seeing this evolve.  This
is just a glimpse to what is
possible today.  The first phone
featuring Tango enabled d
capabilities was Lenovo.  The
second phone is the Zen phone
that customers s can experience
in    in Verizon stores later
this summer.  I really believe
this is the beginning.
We have seen a variety of great
applications s again to appear
that take advantage of these new
capabilities.  For example we
have tools that can help you
measure the size of a table in
case you're interested in buying
one for your dining room or you
can do things like walk around
your house with the tracking and
depth sensor to generate a heat
map of the Wi-Fi           the
Wi-Fi signal strength of your
apartment or building and this
helps you find dead spots.  You
can even              You can
even estimate          estimate
the square footage of your
apartment which might come in
handy if you're thinking about
moving into a new place or
renegotiating your rent.
There's games that allow you to
carry a toy box right in your
bokt           your pocket.
Yesterday you heard about the
visual positions service from
Clay which opens s up many new
experiences around indoor
navigation and location.  We use
the wide angle camera and the
Tango phone to give us a broad
view of the environment and this
allows s us to generate large
scale descriptions s of the
space.  This enables s
centimeter scale accurate
positions within the building.
It's at lot like GPS but rather
than talking to
talking to satellites s it's
using features that are are just
a few       a few feet away to
calculate its position.  This is
what we use in the art science
museum that allows s us to
anchor trees in the environment.
In stores like Lowe's it can
get you walking directions
directly to an item sitting on
the shelf.  So even at home we
started shopping with our phones
more and more.  And having
confidence in what you're
you're with      with about
you're about to
buy is more important than of.
Another area where shopping for
close           for clothes is
challenging.  Retailers   ers
know that buying clothes are
sometimes difficult and
customers often return those
items but this is expensive for
the retailer to process those
returns as well as time
consuming for you as a consumer
to try on those items.  It would
be nice to get a sense of
whether a product will fit
before you buy it.  Let me give
you a demo of the dressing room
app by gap
Gap.
So what we have here I have the
Zen phone AR.  And the Gap app
has a small jar here with some
clothing options.  And we are
going on a trip in just a few
months and I'm trying to wear
lighter clothes for the
summertime and my brother is
going on a trip as well so we
would like to have matching
white cotton shirts.  I'm going
to drag over this man
mannequin with this clothing
item.  It asks what is the body
size?  Like me my brother is a
little bit at the extra large
end of the scale.  When we put
try it on -- whoops, let me try
it again.
Let me try that again
.  Oh.  We'll switch back to the
video.
It was working fine just before
the demo.  I don't know what
happened.
We are still in the early days s
of what we feel like would be
possible with these technologies
and it let's us see things in
new ways that we couldn't
couldn't see before.
So it helps us learn more about
the environment, it helps us
find our way through spaces and
share knowledge with other
people        people.  But one
of the things that it helps us
do is learn better especially
when we are able to make
connections s with those who are
seeing the same thing at the
same time from their own unique
perspective.  And this way the
power of AR isn't          AR
isn't just adding digital
objects to            objects to
the camera view in front of us
but it could be adding shared
meaning to the interaction
between people.  So to tell you
more about how shared AR
experiences can help in the
classroom led me hand it off to
Jen Holland.  Thank you.
(Applause). , everyone.  Thanks,
Johnny.  I'm Jennifer Holland
and I'm the education program
manager on Daydream.  Johnny
shared some updates about the
applications s of Tango as well
as areas where we think AR can
have a big       a big immediate
impact.  Education is just one
of those areas.  And my team
took advantage of Tango sensor
sensor stack and built a
tool for schools so that
teachers could create immersive
experiences with their students.
And that's the same technology
that's actually available to
all of you.
Two years ago we launched
expeditions s VR.  And we built
more than 600 tours       tours
and we heard from thousands of
kids from around the world who
have sent us personal letters
sharing house expeditions s has
inspired d them.  We have
learned a great deal from
talking to            talking to
the over 2 million teachers and
students who have actually used
it.  And one of the most
important things that my team
learned was that you really need
to embrace the key functions of
a classroom.  That is, students
engaging, interacting and
learning with each other as well
as their teacher.
Tango's camera and sensor are
what
makes this interaction possible
in real      realtime.  And I
promise you those kids are not
taking selfies in their class.
Teachers are able to accurately
map the physical classroom and
place       place 3D objects s
like one of Mike Jazayeri
one of
Michael            of Michael
anglo's statutes s so the
students can look at the statute
together in realtime
anglo's
statutes so the students can
look at the statute together in
realtime.  You can see up close
or take a step back and be able
to point out new discovers on a
statute together.  And that's
powerful because it's not each
individual student looking at
their own object like a while
category five hurricane
hurricane.  It's as
if you actually brought the
hurricane into the classroom.
from a strand of DN    DNA to
one of Saturn           of
Saturn's rings together and
those objects s don't disappear
when the students look away.
And a teacher is able to point
out specific things on the
object to suit the lesson.  Just
think       think how cool it
would be for a teacher to
transform their entire classroom
into a world class art museum
museum and display the
works of Van Gogh, Monet, or
even the Mona Lisa right on the
same classroom walls.  As an
education product team we are
committed to leveraging the same
Tango technology available to
you and tweaking it slightly to
give teachers a tool to create
immersive experiences each and
every day in their classroom.
And just like we did with
editions vcht
with expeditions s VR we are
going to be bringing it to
schools through the pioneer
program.  If you're a developer
really excited about building AR
lessons s with us, let us know
by expressing interest on our
partner page.
That's expeditions s AR.  That
is just one thing that you can
do with                 you can
do with Tango and we are really
excited to            excited to
see what all of you come up
with.  Now let's switch gears
and talk about another part of
the immersive computing spectrum
.  Let me welcome Mike to tell
you the latest about Daydream.
Our platform for high
performance mobile VR.
(Applause) snis     .
» MIKE JAZAYERI:  Hi, good
morning, everyone.  I'm Mike
Jazayeri and I'm the director of
product management for Daydream
.  Daydream serves as the
foundation of our investments s
in immersive computing.  We
began working on Daydream in
2015.  Today I'm excited to
I'm excited to
tell you about what is next for
Daydream but first a quick
refresher on how we got here.
The first version of Daydream
launched in November and was
built on three core elements s.
The Daydream ready spec for
phones
, a high performance
performance.  We
promised to             promised
to create a large ecosystem of
Daydream devices s.  In six
months there are eight Daydream-
ready devices s.  Samsung's
flagship SA and SA plus will
soon be Daydream ready.  They're
fantastic phones and you're
going to love the Daydream
experience on them.  LG's next
flagship phone       phone will
also be Daydream ready.  In
addition to these new partners
s, existing partners will have
more Daydream-ready phones.  So
when you put all that you
together there will be
will be tens of millions s of
Daydream-ready phones in
consumers hands.  I want to you
thank you on partners s who have
been working hard on that.
(Applause).
So that's the start.  What is
coming next?  This year at
Google I/O     I/O we are a
nouns         announcing two new
events s.  The first is a brand
new category of    of stand
alone headsets s, second is an
update to the software flat form
.  We are going to call it
Daydream
Euphrates.  The stand alone
headset tanks       takes
everything we love about
smartphone VR and make
makes it even better.  The
hardware is in one integrated
integrated device.
And you can get into VR in just
seconds.  Just put the headset
on, you're ready to go.  No
extra wires, PC or set up
required.  For these stand alone
headsets s we wanted to
wanted to create a large
ecosystem of devices s and
content.  Doing so requires
great hardware.  We partnered
with Qualcomm.  This is
featuring the incident happen
the snap
dragen        dragon chip set
and     and high e   eperforming
high
performing sensors s.  A
reference             A
reference headset isn't
isn't all we are doing.  We are
partnering with two
with two device makers s.    s.
Hvs       s.  HTC needs no
introduction in the world of
of VR.  They're going to bring
their expertise in headset
design and building high
performance to Daydream.  Our
other partner is    is Lenovo.
.  They're already a pioneer
in AR and they are going to
bring that same pioneering
experience to Daydream.
Powerful hardware also requires
powerful software.  That's where
the next version of Daydream,
Daydream Euphrates comes in.
It's making VR content front and
center, the content that you
build.  And it's making it easy
for users to share that VR
content with friends and family
whether they're         they're
sitting next to them or around
the world.  Daydream Euphrates
takes advantage of even deeper
support for Android VR.  If you
think about it, Android phones
have been designed for device or
Android have been designed for
sgiss           for devices s
primarily on touch screens.  We
had to build a new VR manager
where all the system VI will be
I will be accessible on
VR.  Also we are updating the
home experience.  First we are
going to make it easy to
discover the best content in VR.
You'll see a list of
continuously updated content
mixing thousands of videos,
experience, games and apps.
Once you're in the experience we
don't want to break that sense
of immersion so Daydream
Euphrates has a dashboard and it
appears s right on top of any
app.  It's super fast to load
and let's you stay in VR.  You
don't have to leave the
experience to check a
notification, change settings or
even to switch apps.  Now that
we meade          we made it
he's dwroi stay in
easy to stay in VR we
want to make         to let you
share that experience with
others.  Cast support is coming
to Daydream.
(Applause).
» Thank you.  It's one of our
top-requested features.  With
this feature you'll be able to
pull up the dashboard and select
a casting destination.   .  As
you go from app to app your
castzation            cast
station stays.  It goes from
individual experience to shared
experience.  Casting is good for
people physically near you but
what about everybody else?  We
are adding the ability to cam
tour screen
to capture screen shot or short
video and share it.  Thank you.
Frf (applause)
.
(Applause).
» Thank you.  In addition to
this there's many other features
including many for developers.
You can learn more about that
in our other situations or on
our developer website.  We have
tens of millions s of Daydream
ready phones by the end of the
year, a new class of stand alone
headsets s and a upgrade to
Daydream Euphrates for both
smartphone VR and stand alone
headsets s.  I speak about
making it easier to share your
experience with others.  We
think it's critical for users to
keep them engaged.  Let me
welcome Erin from the YouTube VR
team who is going to tell you
about nings the YouTube VR team
is doing.  Thank you.
(Applause).
» ERIN TEAGUE:  Hi, Erin.  I'm
Erin.  I'm a product manager
from the VR team at YouTube.  We
made an early bet on 360 degree
and 3D video and thought a lot
about how to build the YouTube
VR app from the ground up on
Daydream.  It does everything
you love about upt but in
YouTube but in a way
that feels natural.  Since we
launched, people's responses
have blown us away.  Every time
I pop in there's something new
to splors               new to
explore from sports highlights
s, deep      deep sea dives to
learning about dinosaurs s.  No
matter what you're passionate
about YouTube in VR can take you
there thanks to the huge
library of hundreds s of
thousands of immersive videos.
So there are all these amazing
places you can go, see and learn
about.  You probably want to
share these experiences with
other people.  It's just better
that way.  From co-watching
partys to creators s engageing
with their fans, YouTube already
has an incredible community
build around its content and we
want to bring that to VR.  So
here is a sneak peak into
something that we are working
on.  Later this year we will be
rolling out an update that let's
you co-watch YouTube videos
with other people.  Talk about
them live.  And share the
experience all in the same
virtual room.  Everyone will be
able to            be able to
customize the way they look in
VR.  And with just a click you
can sync in to what others are
watching too.  Anyone can
correct with other Gore
gorillas s fans to watch a
virtual video in the front row.
It goes way beyond games,
entertainment and music.  So
many creators s use VR to
inspire em path         empathy
and compassion.  There's no
There's no other
technology that let's you walk
in someone else's shoes,
experience things you can't in
real life, and gain a new
perspective on important Tom pib
on
important topics s.  With this
update to YouTube VR and the
addition of casting there will
soon be more ways for you to
enjoy VR together.  Now let me
pass this off to Andrey who is
going to talk to you about tools
for VR and developers.  Thank
you.
(Applause).
» ANDREY DORONICHEV:  Good
morning, everyone.  I'm Andrey.
I lead apps and developers   er
tools at Daydream.  So much
exciting progress on AR and VR
platform side but of course flat
forms                      of
course plat farms
platforms are defined by the
best experiences built by
developers   ers like you.  To
build great stuff and great
tools.  I want to talk about new
tools that it rate faster,
better graphics and immersive
experience to the whole web.
First let's talk about iteration
time.  It's early days s of
immersive computing so it's all
about experimenting.  You need
to be able to try many new ideas
as quickly as possible.  To
evaluate VR content you need to
experience it first hand in the
target hardware.  From many
model            many mobile
developers   ers it may take
minutes to when you make the
change on the editor to when you
see the device.  I can hit
build, go toast myself a bagel
and come back before it's done
deploying.  We knew we had to
take the iteration time down
from minutes to seconds s.  And
that is why we built instant
preview.  This is a tool that
let's you make changes in your
desk top and instantly see them
in your VR device.  Thank you.
Instant preview is deeply
integrated in both the editor
and the mobile device.   .  We
send the sensor data
to the PC which emulates s and
renders the     s the scene and
the result is sent back to the
device.  And the cool
the cool thing is we can do it
with low latency so you can use
it in VR while teaking
interactions in real time
realtime.  The result is a
continuous uninterrupted
development flow.  Instant
preview is launching today
today.  You can download it
right now.  Check it out.
(Applause).
Now, let's talk about graphics
s.  VR makes you feel like
you're somewhere else so the
visual fidelity of the virtual
environment matters a lot.  And
of course with six degrees
degrees of freedom
devices s you can't get away
with wrapping
a 360 panorama
panorama as a background.
However what you can render in
realtime depends on the amount
of power you have available.
There's a huge gap to what
you can do on a four watt model
device, 400 watt PC.  But what
if we could bridge this gap?
What if we could achieve desk
top level on graphics s on a
mobile head      headset like
our stand alone.  We can't
change laws of physics s.  I
want to introduce
a new tool called sur
Seurat      Seurat after the
great French painter.  You can
took a tool and run it in mobile
VR in realtime.  How does this
work?  As a developer you define
the volume within which you
want the user to move around and
use a scene.  You also define
target parameters s like number
of polygons s and then you let
the tool do its magic.  It takes
dozens s of images s and then
it automatically generates s an
entirely new 3D scene that looks
identical to the original but
is dramatically simplified.
(Applause).
Yeah, it's pretty cool.  And you
still can have dynamic
interactive elements s in it.
So yeah it's pretty cool.  But
wait a minute.  If we can do
something like this why would
you stop at desk top dprafks
topographics s?
What                     top
graphics.  What if you take
something from a movie.  Let me
show you a project we worked on
with ILMX
X lab.  One of the goals is to
take you inside of star warts
Star Wars.  Let's
see what they have been able to
do with Seurat.  Let's role the
video
.
» ILM X lab's mission is to
create immersive premium story
based experiences and our goal
is for people to step inside the
inside the worlds of
our stories and in this case
into the world of Star Wars.
» When there are events s,
locations, characters s,
something that has to be
fabricated, they turn to visual
facts for that imagery.
» The depth of the world that we
would like to you step into is
as thoughtful and creative
creative and exacting
as anything we might put into
our films.
» This new technology is
enabling us to do something we
have been trying to do for pay
while.                        to
do for a while.
» When X lab was approached by
Google they said they can take
our ILM renders s and make them
run in realtime.  Turns out it's
true.
» You can have very dense
complex scenes with
sophisticated shading that
traditionally can't run in
realtime in an enjoin
an engine.
» When I see people looking at
the floor I really think we are
on to something.
» That potentially opens the
door
to cinematic realizeism in VR.
(Applause)
.
» MIKE JAZAYERI:  So ILM X lab
brought this world       world
on to our mobile head settle.
settle
headset.  This scene is around
50 million triangles
triangles.  Normally each frame
takes an hour to render off line
on a high performance machine.
However after processing with
Seurat it takes 13 millisecond
-milliseconds s per
frame on a mobile GPU.
(Applause)
.
And it looks as good         as
good as the original.  How cool
is that?  Well, with that
technology you as a developer
will be able to build visually
stunning
on a mobile GPU.
(Applause).
And it looks as good as the
original.  How cool is that?
Well, with that technology you
as a developer will be able to
build visually stunning
experiences while still target
ing mobile VR hardware.  We are
currently experimenting with a
small         a small set of
partners.  We will start rolling
out the tool later this year so
please stay tuned.
Let's talk about the world's
largest developer ecosystem, the
web.  Three years ago we
coauthored web VR spec.  It
allows s developers   ers to
build immersive 3D applications
with Javascript and Web GL and
run them in the browser.  It
adapts s to different kinds of
devices s and it's easy to
distribute it with a link.
Imagine you're a user in a VR
headset.  Where do you go to
discover a web VR experience?
How do you surf the web in    in
VR?  I'm excited to
I'm excited to
announce we are bringing the
full Chrome browser in VR.  Let
me show you a preview.
(Applause).
You'll be able to use Daydream
controller to follow links.  And
for web VR experiences you just
get transported into fully
immersive worlds.  And of course
you'll be able to watch any wed
video in                  any
web     web video in a theatre-
like environment with a large
screen.  It's the same app for
browsing in two D     2 D   2 D
which means all of my Bookmarks
and tabs are already there.
Things just work.  Browsing in
VR feels brat            feels
great and it's coming to Chrome
for Android later this year.
But Web is not only for Virtual
Reality.  We    We actually see
big potential in the context of
augmented reality, too.  You see
web connects s world's
information.  And AR connects s
information with the physical
world.  So together they can be
applied for solving real life
problems.  I want to show you
what AR features in the browser
could look like.
Let's say you're searching for a
new coffee table.  You're
probably browsing online stores
and looking at some pictures on
your phone but you don't want
pictures of the phone, you want
the furniture in your room.
This is one example where
connecting physical world and
information would be very handy.
With AR-enabled d browser your
favorite website could ask you
to mark the physical space you
have available and it would only
show you the items that fit in
this area.  And of course you'll
be able to preview search
results in the context of your
actual room from any angle.
le.
(Applause).
» ANDREY DORONICHEV:  Thank you.
You didn't have to install a
new app just for that.  Everyone
you see here
.  Everything is
see     see here is built with
JavaScript and running on an
experimental browser.  We are
enable        enable developers
ers to integrate it into
existing websites.  Just like we
we did with Web VR we are
starting an experimental build
of Chromium.  It's available
today.  You can download it from
git hub.  I'm excited to see
what the community does with it.
Our goal is to make Web VR and
Web AR first class citizens s
in all browsers s.  And that is
it for developer tools.  Thanks
so much for spending some of
your morning with us.  We look
forward to partnering with you,
making sure you have both
platforms s and the tools to
bring your next great idea to
life.  Make sure you check out
our other talks and come over to
Tango booth to check out the
demo.  Thank you, very much.
(Applause)
.
(Session concluded)
.  Google I/O
.
Google I/O     I/O 2017.     .
May 18, 2017.
10:30 a.m.
Zero to app:  Develop with
Firebase.
(Standing by)
Firebase          football
Firebase
football          Firebase
.
» Good morning everyone and
welcome to the second day of
Google I/O     I/O.  Hopefully
you met a lot of really great
people, learned about the cool
est technology and seen some
great product launches.  But
there's one launch that you
haven't seen.  And I'm so
I'm so confident in this launch
that on stage at Google I/O
I/O I'm announcing I'm
leaving Google to start a start
up to build this app.  And in
short, this idea is so
revolutionary, I want you all of
you to share your story
story with your friends, with
your family, with everyone on
the snaet              on the
internet.  You deserve to share
your story.  Nobody has done
this before.  Actually
.  Absolutely nobody.  I'm
confident we will tb first
we will westbound
we will be
the first to market.  We have
meetings scheduled an hour from
now.  But I think I was a little
too confident.  We actually
don't have anything yet so I
have this great idea but in
order to get funding I need to
show that it's a viable concept.
I need an Android app, iOS app
and Web app to prove that we
can get users.  So I have
a bunch of really smart people
at Google and they told me build
an app that looks like this.
So have an application, your Web
app, your mobile app, that
talks to some database server
and that database server proxies
all the app requests.  That
server is going to have all of
my authentication logic,
business logic.  It will control
who can read and write the
stories, and where those stories
get sent.  But that sounds like
just a ton of work and I
scheduled meetings for like 45
45 minutes from now so I
can't build this alone.  I've
asked a couple of my friends to
come out and help he.  Jenny,
Frank and Kat, can you guys help
me?
(Applause)
.
» Love it.  We all have a friend
like that, right, who comes up
with this great app idea and
then sort of gives you 30
minutes to build it because how
hard is it to build an app,
especially live here on stage?
So it's a tricky situation.  We
have to build three applications
applications and
we have what did he say?  30
minutes?
So
We are going to be using
Firebase to build these
applications s.  And that means
that the application code talks
directly to our powerful managed
services.  This means that
Firebase takes care of all the
things like scaleability and
security.             security
so that we can focus on building
the features that our users
love.
It takes a bit of time to set
everything up so while the team
is prepping on their lab tops s,
I'm going
on their laptops I'm
going to talk about Firebase and
building this application.
Remember we are building a story
-sharing app so we are taking a
picture on our phone, selecting
a picture on our lap-top, and
then sharing it with the other
users of the app.  First things
we need no         need to do is
allow the users to sign in and
we are using Firebase
application with that.  Second
we need a place where we can
store and share the photos so
for that we are using Cloud
storage.  Finally we need a way
to store and synchronize
metadata and that's the Firebase
database.  We are going to go
through each of these feature,
I'm going to explain how we use
it in the app then then switch
over to the code and see how it
works in practice.
So you're going to be
experiencing first hand how easy
it is to build an app with
Firebase.  First up Firebase
authentication.
It's our secure serverless sign
in solution.  We have taken all
the complexity of storing e-mail
addresses and passwords and
wrapped them in a single cross
platform API.  That means that
your users can sign in with
Google, Facebook, Twitter,
GitHub.  We also support phone
authentication.  Even if your
users don't have an account,
they can sign in from your phone
and continue using the
application.  To speed things up
we are going to be using
Firebase UI which is our     our
open source library for
authentication.  It handles s
this is a new users, returning
use,      user do they want to
sign in with Facebook.  It
handles s a lot.  It's an open
source library built by the
identity experts at Google and
it includes years of experience
and best practices for signin
flows.  I think that's pretty
much what we need to know.  Can
we switch to the split screen to
do some coding?
Okay.  So to speed things up we
are going to be building all
three applications
applications at the same time.
So let's          So let's see.
.  At the top left you see
Mike's screen and he's building
the iOS version of our fire
stories app.  Kat is working on
the web vehicles.
on the web
version.  On the top right you
see Jenny's screen.  That
doesn't         doesn't look
like Java code that I'm used to.
Did you switch over last night
?
>> Yes I switched it last night.
code that you need to write for
this.  They have already built
the basic framework for the
application so they have added
the layouts s they need to stair
the stories and
to share the stories
and the bottom where they can
send it.  If we now run the app,
we can access the devices s
camera or the local file brower
and we can take other select
a picture.
But if we hit send, nothing
happens.  That's because we are
not using Firebase yet.  So in
the bottom right you see the
Firebase console.  This is where
you manage all of your Firebase
projects.  We have already
skreeated           created a
project that will serve
serve as the back end for this
application.  All these
applications are talking against
the same back end so they share
the same list of users, the
same file storage and the say
database.  That is great because
that means they're sharing all
their states.  They have taken
the configuration data of this
project and added it to each of
the platforms s so the apps can
find their services
on the Google surfers   ers.
We                            on
the Google servers s.  We add d
script includes.  So with that
I think we are ready to start
coding.
First thing we need to do is we
take the features that we are
using about Firebase and impart
them from the SD        the SDK
into our code.  We do this in
one goal for all three features
features we are using,
off, storage and database.  You
can see the code looks exactly
the same for every feature so we
have a cross feature
consistency with Firebase.
That's great because it allows
you to start using new features
quickly.  If you glance from
screen to screen you see that
it's really also very similar
between platforms s.  And that
is great because it means that
you learn Firebase on one
platform and then when you
switch to another flat
platform you     you take what
you've learned and use it ton
it on the new platform
also.  I think          .
Firebase authentication, let's
get to that.  First we need to
configure Firebase for the
providers we want to use.
So today we are only using
Google on sign-in because we
only have a few minutes left.
We also in the Firebase console
enabled d this provider.  Next
we are going to wait until the
user clicks the     s the sign-
in button and when they
they do we start the sign-in
flow.  It triggers s all the
complex flows that you can
imagine.   .  If users signs in
on an iOS tomorrow but an
Android device the same after
they still have the say stories.
When they want to sign in with
Facebook today but Google
tomorrow it handles s all
account linking for you.  What
we need to do is          to do
is listen for when the
authentication state changes.
When it does it's either 1 of 2
things.  Either        Either
authentication succeeded or the
user did not signed in.  If the
user signed in we hide the sign
in button and enable any other
UI elements s that required an
authenticated d users.  That's
all we need to do.  We have sign
in working.  Let's see who gets
there first.  I think Kat is
already signing in.  You can see
that you get pop ups s, we get
to pick our account.  We get an
account picker.  All that is
handled for us with the minimum
code that you just saw.  But
just signing in on an app is not
very interesting so let's
so let's switch back
to slides and see how you're
going to be using cloud storage.
storage before you know it's our
petabyte scale storage solution
.  It provides a SD      a SDK
that allows s you to upload
files securely directly from
your device.  You can ensure
only authorized d users have
access to those files from their
device.  Within every you
upload a new file through
Firebase you also get a download
URL.  This is an unguessible
URL that provides read-only
access to that same file and
that is great for our
for our fire stories app today
because we can use that to share
the image between all the
users.  I think there's nothing
more we need no         need no
know about
need to know about Cloud storage
.  Let's switch back to the code
.  We are back in the code.
Remember we already imparted the
feature
imported the feature sow we have
a local file what the user took
with
we have a local file what the
user took with a camera or
selected with the file browser.
We need too          need to
figure out where we are going to
store that file in Cloud
storage.  It's going to
assistance of two pieces
pieces.  The first piece is the
user's UID      's UID.  This is
the I dents indication of
the
identification of the
authenticated d user.  We make
sure what the files from the
various users end up in
different locations.  That is
great because that means we can
use Firebase's security rules to
ensure that only authorized d
user has access to their files.
So if Mike uploads a new story
only he can change that picture.
The second part of the path is
really just a nung        a
unique file name.  Since we are
writing to the same Cloud
storage application we    we
want      want to make sure we
don't overlap files.  To take
the storage reference
reference we juste       just
created we tell the Firebase to
put the file to that laeks
to that location.
That is all we need to do to
start the upload in the
backgrounds.
Now think of all the things we
did not have to do here.  We did
not spin up any threads, there
were no connectors s, no
background tasks s.  All we did
was tell Firebase to start
uploading the file and it went
to work.  All we have to do is
wait for          wait for the
upload to complete.  And when it
does, 1 of 2 things can happen.
Either the upload succeeded or
it failed.  If it failed we
take the error message we get
from Firebase and show it to the
user.  If the upload succeeded
we take the downloaded URL of
the file that was uploaded and
display that on the local
screen.
This is all we need.  So if you
now run this app we will be able
to up employed
to upload files to clout
to sloud          to
Cloud storage.  I see Kat is
already selecting an image.  We
don't really see a lot yet.  If
in the console we switch to the
storage tab in the Firebase
console on the bottom right, Kat
, can you switch on the console?
Can we go back to the split
screen?  Thank you.
So we have files here now.
These files were just uploaded
but not a really impressive way
of up employed
uploading a file but there is a
really cute dog in there.
So clearly we can upload files
to the Cloud, not really what we
wanted yet.  Nothing we
.  So we are going to
be using the third Firebase
feature to share the information
between our users.  Let's
switch back to the presentation.
est feature and it's still one
of our most popular services.
We have hundreds of thousands of
applications that rely on our
database every day.  The
Firebase database is a cloud-
hosted no SQL database.   .  And
if you've ever modeled your
data with JSON you know it's
very flexible.  This is a data
model that we are using today.
At the top level you see we have
a note called stories.  Under
that we have a note for each
individual story.  And for each
of those stories we keep the
download URL.  We keep the title
the title that the
user entered for that story.  We
keep if user              keep
the user ID    ID of the user
that created the story.  Having
the user ID    ID allows s us to
access the story           the
story with security rules.  That
is great because it means when
Kat enters a story only she can
change the tight of
the title of that store.
story.  We call our
database a realtime database.
We do that because of the way
you read your data from it.
With most daebs you
most databases s you
do something like select from
story.  With Firebase you attach
a listener or observer to the
story's notes and from that
moment on Firebase will tell you
when ever something changes
under the story's note.  So when
Jen uploads a new story, Kat
and Mike get informed of that I
instantly.
instantly.  And
when Jen responds to the story,
Mike gets the updates s.  This
is realtime synchronization.
It's really easy.  Let's switch
back to the code and add the
final feature to the app.    .
We already imparted the database
.  We are going to go       to
go back to where we uploaded the
uploaded the file
and added it to the local
screen.  First we are going to
remove that
the database.  We are going to
go back to where we uploaded the
file and added it to the local
screen.  First we are going to
remove that code.  We create a
reference to the story's note in
the database.  Since we point
to that same note in each of the
apps, they're going to be
writing to the same location in
the same database.  That makes
data sharing really easy.  But
since they're writing to the
same location we also need to
make sure we have a unique ID
ID for the story we are create
can.  We are              can.
With that we are ready to write
the metadata.  We take the
reference that we just created
and write the values of our
story to it.  So we write the
download URL that everyone can
display, we write the text that
the user entered, we write the
UID         the UID so the user
can secure access to the story.
We write the path in the Cloud
storage because I think that
might be               that
might come in handy but I'm not
sure where yet, I just have a
feeling.  Now we can run the app
again.  We    We pick a story,
it will write that data to the
database.  If you look at the
bottom right you see we have
open a database panel in the
Firebase console.  Now we are
going to wait for             to
wait for the stories to pour in
.  I see that Mike is already
selecting an image.  Kat is
working.  You can see that the
database lights up as the new
stories come in.  That is great.
But just one problem left.
Smile, you're on camera.
There's one problem left.  It
doesn't         doesn't show on
the local screens anymore.  So
that's the final step we need to
take in our code.  We are
almost done here, folks s.  We
are going to attach a listener
to the same note that we had
before to the story's note.  And
we are going to ask Firebase
for the last ten stories
stories.  Now, from that moment
on when ever a new stories edit
, Firebase will fire the added
event.  And with that event we
get a snapshot of the story.  So
we take the value out of the
snapshot, that's the slaul
that's the
value we just      just wrote
and we display it on the local
screen again by calling it
displayed story.  That's it.  We
are going to do one extra one
because I've been telling about
changing the story so securely
so much that I want to make sure
it works, too.  We are also
going to listen for changes to
the stories which works with a
child changed event.  When
somebody changes a story we get
a snapshot of the updated story.
We take the value and the key
of that story and update to
display on the local screen.  I
think we are ready to run
.
So now you can see that if we
run the app, stories that we
just created actually are
already showing on each local
screen.  So that child added
event that we were talking about
fires immediately for any
existing children.  But now as
they're taking more pictures and
writing more stories, those
stories show up on all screens
within milliseconds.  This is
how you build a multi user story
-sharing application with
Firebase.  In fact, I'm not sure
, I think we are pretty much
done here, Mike.  And it took
what, like 15 minutes?  I think
we have like 40 minutes left to
go play in the bull pit?  Was
was it?
>> What's What is wrong?
>> I'm getting a call, it's our
VC.  Our VC says there's already
a bunch of apps that do
basically this thing.  Wait.
You want what?   ?  Oh my gosh.
Frank, we need to pivot like
now.  Good thing we have 20
minutes left.  So turns out if
you go back to the slides, it
turns out that there are a lot
of apps out there already that
do really thyme
do realtime communication and it
turns out that's so a few years
ago.  And people are interested
in new stuff now.  Specifically
people are tired of reading
texts s and looking at their
pictures.  Instead they want to
look at their pictures and look
at other tiny pictures next to
their big pictures.  So we need
to e mojyfy our app
mojyfy our app
today       today.  It's okay.
Pivots s or    s are hard but we
are thinking ahead.  Our team
has thought of this and created
e moej
mojification
emojification
outcome.  We are prifting.
pifting.  We
pivoting.  I think it has
something to do with the bunsy
the bouncy castle in
the break room.  Anyway we have
to take our original
emojification algorithm and
write it once so we don't have
to import it to all the
platforms s.  Another thing is
our emojification platform is
great but it consumes s a lot of
resources.  Although mobile
devices are faster than ever
before the battery life has been
flat over the last few years
and we knee to make sure
we need to make
sure we save      save our user
's batteries.  And finely
And finally security.  We
have our proprietary
emojification algorithm but as
you build out an application you
end up with      with secrets s
that are part of your app.  If
you put them in to your app and
deploy them to the world some of
your nefarious users are going
to find that information and do
bad things with it.  We don't
want that information to leaning
to leak out because
that would ruin us.  It's even
more okay because the same skunk
works engineering team has also
come up with a solution to the
problem.
Turns out Cloud functions are
the solution to the problem.  So
Cloud functions allow us to
take our already written
JavaScript emojification along
rim           along rim
algorithm and deploy to
it the Cloud.  We only have to
write it once and deploy it to
all our apps.  It also allows s
us to run on Google servers s in
the Cloud.  And since it's
deploy             it's deployed
to the Cloud we don't have to
worry about people extracting
information from our deployed
apps.
So we have a conclusion, we have
a plan and we have some jaef
some JavaScript.  The
first thing to do is update the
architecture
slide.  We have our application
on one side that this is all th
e different applications s, all
the platforms s.  They're using
the Firebase SDQ     SDQ to
communicate
SDK to communicate with the
database and storage.  We are
going to shift the apps up a
little bit and plop Cloud
functions right here.  Cloud
functions kind of act like
another client.  It's like a
super client that's there all
the time and can always wrach
can always watch
for changes that happened, make
all those heavy lifting
operations and push them back to
Firebase to the database and to
storage where the clients will
automatically be notified just
like as if another client did
the update.  So I can talk about
this all day.  But why don't I
just show you with some code?
Sound good?   ?  Switch back to
the code.  So here we are.  And
we have down in the lower corner
Kat is our JavaScript wiz and
she was the one who helped us
with this and she will take the
helm today.  She started out
with a few imparts
imparts like our emojification
along rim but
along       algorithm but she's
kwet            she's ready to
get coding.  This is where you
wire it up to       up to the
Firebase database.  Here you can
see it has a path to Firebase
and it's listening for rights on
that location.  Because they're
integrating with already
existing app, this is the same
location          location where
our stories appear today.  It's
going to behave just like an
app.  We are going to have a
snapshot handy.  Next we are
going to unpack the title with
borg           with boring old
texts from the snapshot.  Then
we are going to do the magic,
take that title and pass it off
to our emojification algorithm
which will take the title in and
a wonderful stream of emoji
will come out.  We are going to
take that e moejfyd           e
moejfied
mojified title.  The
behavior for functions is
different than on the clients.
It will trigger for each right
than on the slightly more
specific child event so we are
going to add a short circuit to
the top to make sure we don't re
e moejfy something that it's
already processed.  We are are
ready           ready to deploy
something that it's already
processed.  We are ready to
deploy.  We don't have to deploy
the apps, we can just run it
and all the new titles that get
get added are going to be e
moejfyd d and people can be
super happy looking at those
pictures
emojifyd and people can be super
happy looking at those pictures
and that's great, right
and people can be super happy
looking at those pictures and
that's great, right?
>> Hold on. My friend dog is
calling.  And my friend dog says
dog says been miss
labeling dogs.  People are
really bad on identifying dogs
and calling them sheep and
bananas.  What's that?  You're
afraid people will upload bad
photos?
» Who would do bad things on the
internet.
» You can see the temptation.
It looks like we have some more
work cut out for us so let's
so let's go back to
the slides because I've got an
idea.  We'll be able to use
machine learning.  We will be
able to fix this problem and I
bet we'll be able to get the V
C's on board if we can say we
are using machine learning.  How
can we use it?  Well we'll
still have people upload their
photos s same as before but
instead of making them type in
the title we will just figure
out what is in the image and
perform image verification on
that.  While we are there people
seem to really en joip not
having                    enjoy
not everything to read.  In fact
I'm not sure my friend dog can
read or type so getting ready of
the title is probably a great
move.  We can also get rid of
the complicated images s and
keep the super simple beautiful
emoji.  So it looks something
like this.  Just a giant stream
of emoji.  It will be fantastic.
We spent all of our time
engineering on the emojification
algorithm and haven't spent any
time on machine learning.  Well
good thing we are at Google I/O
I/O and Cloud has some APIs
that can help us with this.
Let's just put a Cloud on it.
Every Firebase project is also a
Cloud project.  That means we
can use the same project to
access the cloud APIs s and the
Cloud SD    SDK's.  In this case
let's make use of the vision
API     API which will allow us
to look at an image, determine
what is in that and based on
that we will be able to perform
our emojification algorithm and
spin out a stream of emoji.
Where is the architecture
diagram?  We have koud clungs
have Cloud
functions now that can listen to
Firebase.  Now we just need a
little bit of room to fit in
in one more icon so we will
shift everything over and bam we
have      have room for a Cloud
vision API.  We will create a
new Cloud function which run-ins
a secure environment so we can
put in our project information
so we can talk directly to the
Cloud vision Pay API doshgs
vision
API and run it back sta
back to the babies
to the database.
So let's          So let's code
one last time.  The first thing
we are going the nt
going the to want to
do here is hook up to       up
to the vision
here is hook up to the vision
API.  You'll        You'll want
to be focusing here on the
bottom left.  We are using the
same ID    ID and going to make
use of the Cloud SD    SDK as
well, the Cloud storage SDK as
well.  Now that we hooked up our
API we are going to go ahead
and define a new function.  It's
list he ening          he en
ing                    It's
listening to the same place in
the database because we want to
pick up the same images s.  We
can fire up multiple functions
from the same place.  Instead of
grabbing the title which we no
longer have we want to grab the
image using the file path that
Frank so kindly snuck in for us
earlier.  Once we have the file
path we will be able         be
able to use the storage sd
the storage SD
SDK to grab a reference to
that file.  With that new
reference we will be able to go
ahead and pass that to the
vision API to detect labels s
and find out what is in our
image.
Once we have the labels s, the
response from the vision API, we
want to filter out just the
labels s.  And then we can e
moej
mojify       emojify just
our labels s.  Once we have the
emoji we need to write it back
back to our database
to our database
.  Here instead of writing to
the same location we are going
to write to a new location,
emojis s.  This allows s us to
differenceiant
to differentiate between who
can write and view stories,
versus who can look at the emoji
s s.  Honestly everyone deserves
s emojis s so we are going to
open this up to the world.  We
will deploy our new function and
any new images will new get
emojifyd d and labeled
automatically.  We'll update the
clients so that they now list
tone      tone           listen
to the emoji's field instead of
the story's field.
emoji.  A nice definitely
comprehensible stream of emoji.
So what do you think, Mike?  Do
you think we are going to be
able to get that funding we need
?
» MIKE McDONALD:  I don't know,
Kat.  I'd sea         I'd say
let's let our first couple users
to take a crack at it and see
what they think.  Mean time we
will do a quick recap.  Can you
switch back to the slides,
please.
At the beginning of the talk I
presented this problem.  How do
we build an app in under an hour
that we can present to our
investors s?  And Frank came on
stage and showed us the easiest
way to do that, to use Firebase,
Google' mobile platform to
build your application for
Android, iOS and the Web.  He
used Firebase authentication to
securely sign in our users.
Cloud storage to upload and
share those files.  And the real
time database
to synchronize file metadata
across all of our clients.
Firebase let's you build your
app quickly without everything
to worry about managing servers
s or infrastructure, writing
your own code          own auto
thent                own
authentication code.  Then Jen
and Kat showed us how to extend
or apps functionality using
Cloud function and Cloud vision
API.  It let's us protect our
proprietary
emojification algorithms s and
then enhance them with the power
of machine learning.  Since you
don't work with Kat, Jenny and
Frank we provided a number of
other tools in Firebase to
provide that level of support
when you have to go and build
your application and pitch to
your investors s.  Fbs       s.
Fbs       s.  Firebase offers
high quality application, dev
tools and high quality free
technical support.  If you're
interested in diving deeper to
any of these concepts with
Firebase there are a number of
other talks available today and
tomorrow on stage seven in the
main area.  And all of us and
our team members will be
will be available in sandbox H
if you have any additional
questions.  Let's check in on
those users again, let me give
them a call.
Hay
Hey, what did you think of the
app?  Hmm.  So you don't think a
stream of e moejib
emoji is a particularly useful
useful app?  That's not
great news, team.  What are you
doing, Kat?
» KAT FANG:  I'm coding.
» MIKE McDONALD:  Can you speed
that up?  We have fine minutes.
» KAT FANG:  I'm done.
» MIKE McDONALD:  How did you
finish so fast?
» KAT FANG:  I'm really quick.
» MIKE McDONALD:  Let's see what
Kat did.  We need to prove to
our investors s that this app
has traction.  So I need
everyone in the audience
to go to mojiac.io and start
playing around with the app.
Can we switch back to screen
upper
and start playing around with
the app.  Can we switch back to
screen upper one, please.  Let's
see what Kat wripd
Kat whipped up in that 30
seconds.  That was really
impressive, Kat.
» KAT FANG:  Yeah, I know it.
» MIKE McDONALD:  Or
go to mojaic.io, sign in with
your Google account.  Take a
toto              .  I was
talking to            talking to
some of our investors s earlier
and they told me that mobile
social viral gaming is really
popular for some reason so I
guess that's what Kat did, , she
created a social game where you
build, thank you all by the way
for helping fill this in, a
larger emoji because that's
that's what the world needs.
So hopefully this goes well.
And we will         we'll be
able to get a giant ball pitiful
of gummy bears s at our start
up.  Thank you very much and
enjoy the rest of I/O     I/O.
(Session concluded).
.
11:30 a.m.
What's new in Android
development tools.
Development Tools
(Standing by).
» TOR NORBYE:
» XAVIER DUCROHET:
pplause).
» So, good morning.  Welcome to
our session
on what's new in Android
development tools.  My name is
Jamal.  I'm here with with
Xavier and Tor.  As you know,
Android studio is the official
for developing apps provided by
Google.  We work hand in hand to
ensure all the features are
tightly integrated inside of
Android studio.  Its      .
It's our teams mission to ensure
that he                   to
ensure that we are are efficient
and productive developers
ers.  I thank you for your
feedback so far in making
Android studio
great.  Before we jump into the
new features I want to spend a
few moments talking about the
features we launched since we
last spoke with you last year in
case you missed them.  Last
year I/O gave you a preview of
Android studioone
studio 2.2 which included
new things.  At around November
we gave you a preview of
Android studio 2.3 which
included instant run update,
lint baseline and constraint
layout.  And this is
And this past March we had a
few releases of Android studio
2.4.  We are not going to be
releases 2.4.  Instead we are
releasing Android studio 3.0.
(Applause)
.
» JAMAL EASON:  So we made the
shift twor                the
shift for two reasons.  As we
are developing features we
realized all the work going
inside this release didn't seem
indicative of one
change.  A change allows s us
to scale how faster we build
speeds.  We have features across
the entire range of feature
sets from buildings
building, testing and optmation
optimizing your
application.  I'm going to
invite Tor up to go over the
cool features of Android 3.0
3.0 and after that have
have sav come
Xav come up.
» TOR NORBYE:  We picked up tons
of great features that I'm not
going to have time to show.
I'll highlight
highlight a couple.  There's
parameter hints.  And there's
emojis s in comments.  Sometimes
when you're communitying on
slow code you want to use a
snail emoticon.  Anyway the big
news for us is we are supporting
call in.  So in the -- yeah.
(Applause)
.
In the new project wis yard
wizard there's a check box
or in an existing project and it
will walk you through upgrading
your project         project
depend sis.               depend
cies.  Or you can take an
existing class and run it
through a converter.  Sometimes
it does a fantastic job like
here it realized I want        I
want stream interpolation and
it uses structuring declarations
s here.  It sometimes gets
warnings.  It's not always
perfect.  Here is another e
xample.  Here we have a data
class in Java.  There's a one
line version of this you could
write in call in but if you run
it through the convert you
you end up with code that is
completely accurate but not the
most optimal.  It's really a
great starting point.
And typically you massage it a
bit more.  So here is a call in
in file showing several
language features.  You have the
four loop with ranges.  You
have a let statement with a
lambda and a when statement.  We
don't have time to cover the
language today.  There's going
to be talks tomorrow that you
don't want to miss.  We might
start             might start
dauk            start talking
about performance.
So you can invoke the show byte
code window.  This is going to
show the byte code for the
current statement.  If you read
byte code, that's great.  If you
don't, there's a really great
decompile           decompile
button.  When you click on this
I get the equivalent Java code.
Now I can look at this and say
that range loop turns into a
pure why loop and the let
statement is an if check.  So
don't prema             don't
prematurely ily let it president
mice in                      it
optimize in your head
and the let statement is an if
check.  So don't prematurelily
let it optimize in your head.
All the Android link checks that
ran on Java files, there's
about 80 of those, they're all
running on call in as well.
There's no            There's no
gap.
(Applause).
Let's talk about the layout
editors s.  So we launched the
new layout he had ters
editor last year at I/O
I/O and continued work on
it.  There's a better handling
of errors and skon straint
and
concentrate layout.  First we
recently had     had chain.  A
chain is a way       a way to
distribute widget yoit
widgets s.    s.
Say I want to create a
horizontal chain.  There's a
beautiful chain graphic here.
And I can align this
horizontally.  Now there's a
chain cycle button.  I can click
on this to explore how the
chains are behaving.  Another
feature is constraint 1.1.  In
1.1 we have barriers s.  The
easiest way to explain it is to
show it.  If I can move this
widget you can see this line
next to it basically we    we
make sure we don't every lap
with it.  It's a good way to
make layouts s that respond
correctly.  And that's actually
all I'm going to say about
constraint layout because
there's a whole talk about it in
a couple of hours that you
don't want the miss.  Another
feature we    we added in the
support for sample data.  In
your apps you might have a list
for your
recycle         recycle view,
it's pretty common, and it looks
like nothing the layout editor
when you run.  So a couple years
ago we added some support to
deal with this with design time
attributes.  You can put string
in and start approximateing what
your app is going to do.  But
that's terrible.  So we
continued enhancing this.  So
now we have this new sample
resource type so for example I
can pull in some text or pull in
let's say date of the week.
But the real power of this is
when you define your own data.
Here is this new JSON file that
I've created in my project.
This is for a fitness app.
There's various activities that
this app is modeling.  Biking
and walking and so forth.  We
even of         even have some
icons.  I can go into my item
layout that I'm using in the
list and start binding these
things.  So code completion
works here for the app sample
tag.  Picking out all     all
the attributes.  I can hook up
the description property to this
next text vusmt when I come
back to this         to this I
get a layout that looks much
more like the real app.
(Applause)
iew.
When I come back to this I get
a layout that looks much more
like the real app.
(Applause).
The last feature I'm     I'm
going to show is support for
downloadable fonts.  In O you
can declare downloadable fants
fonts, there's lots of
advantages.  The way this works
is I select a text view and in
the layout editor.  In the font
family chooser there's a more
font      font item on the bosmt
when I invoke that I can
produces                I can
browse the online available
fonts.  In search I can pick my
favorite.  You can see I get
this new font resource in my
project and it works the way you
would expect.  Another O
feature we added is support for
adaptive eye sons s.  In
icons s.  We now help you
create these so we help you
with the foreground lay     lay
er.  You can modify the
background layer.  I don't know
if you can tell from the screen
but there's also options to show
safe zones s, grid and so forth
.  So this hopefully helps you
put all
the right bits in the right
places.  There's a device
explorer now finally.  So here
you can go in and explore files
on your file system.  You can
click on files to see them
locally.  And you can right
click on folders s to upload and
download and that kind of thick
kind of thing.
Thank you.
(Applause).
Let's talk about instant apps.
So we have a lot of support for
instant apps.  We have support
in the build system which I
think Xav will talk about.  We
have new whizard   ard for
creating feature modules.  The
hardest part is         part is
to break up your monolithic app.
I'm going to take this simple
example first.  Here I have a
class, I'm going to extract it
so I invoke the margin factoring
.  You can see it offers s to
pull four classes out into this
new module and that's because
this class depends on three
other classes.  You'll pull
along with it resources and
manifest.  Here are
Here is a more realistic example
.  I'm going to try to pull this
activity into its own module.
Here you can see it's pulling a
lot.  We have spa get
spaghetti because my class
depends on this class which is
then pointing at some other
stuff.  This is real spaghetti
so what you have to decide now
is where to cut the spaghetti.
You have to fix the code
afterwards.  We have an initial
version of this in canary one
but this is a feature we are
still working on.
We also improved d the APK and
lies                  d the APK
and             d the APK
analyzer.  What I can do here is
load in an APK that is a
release binary.  Last year we
launched this and had a lot of
support for resources.  This
year we added a bunch of support
for code and decks.  So I can
right click on a class and we
disassemble the byte code for
you.  You can notice that the
packaging here is A dot A dot A.
We didn't write the code that
way.  This is because this
this is a pro-guarded APK.  Now
we have the button for the
mapping file.  When we do that,
let me find if mapping
me find the mapping
file, you can see we now show
the original links instead in
the next file which is pretty
handy.
(Applause).
There are some more      more
featureser here        here I
can right click and we have a
compare           a compare
button on the right.  I need to
keep this class xor
class for the release.  Or
conversely I might be
I might be surprise
I might be
surprised this clays in
this class is in the
release.  We have another
feature for APKs s and that is
APK debugging.  The way this
works is from the welcome screen
or from this here you can point
to a random APK.  Let's see.  I
don't know why it's not showing
my home folder.  I think I'm
having network issues.  This is
very sad.  All right.  I'm just
going to talk through it.
Basically if you're a game
developer we give you a way to
point to an APK and we make a
shell project for you based on
the APK analyzer where we show
you the sources inside the
inside the APK on the
left and let you map sources,
the Java source code as well as
the shared               as the
shared libraries.  We let you
drop in an SO with            an
SO with debugable symbols s.
So I'm really sad that didn't
work.
All right.  Next I should talk
about the profiler.  This is a
really big feature for us with
lots of people working on it.
Here is how it works.  I've
started running my app, it's an
image app.  In fact you probably
see this in the keynote.  I
started running it.  The way the
profiler work is I can open up
the profiler tab and it will
attach to the process.  No
connected devices
s.  I'm going to run it again
.  It's very unhappy.  I'm going
to kill it and start over.
television, isn't       isn't it
?
All right.  It should work on
making that image system boot
faster.
(Applause).
All right.  So here we have it.
And no connected devices s.
Wow.
(Laughter).
You know what, I say we -- there
we go.
(Applause).
it's attach             it's
attached to this process and
it's showing me what is
happening with the CPU, memory
and network.  Let's make some
stuff happen in the app.  I'll
click on an image and, wow,
network is very unhappy.  Okay.
All right.  Super slow.  Anyway
it works because if we look at
the background here and I click
on the memory profiler here we
have the CPU, memory and network
.  The purple dots are my touch
events s.  You can see the
activities happening, things
like stopped and destroyed, it's
very small but it's listing
activity names up here.  Let's
start with the network.  This is
a timeline I can scroll in so
I'm going to click down in the
network area and here I can see
the network traffic and radio
traffic that happened in this
time interval.  I can zoom in on
something like this and it will
show me if network calls that
happened during that time and I
can click on flar         on
particular network requests
.   .  You have to opt in this
so go to your run configure and
config and
and there's a profiling tab.  We
look for usages s of HTTP URL
connection.  If your app is
using that or anything based on
it, and we               on it.
We also added support in Android
O for basically doing this
snumentation
instrumentation
this
instrumentation on the fly that.
Will be         Will be
enabled in an upcoming build of
Android studio.  Let's look at
the CPU profileer.  I'm going to
click in here.  I can see the
thread activity.  I'm going to
jump to be live again.  And then
I'm going to do some stuff.  So
I'll click on this image.  I
forget what I want to do is
start collecting samples.  I'm
clicking on the recording and
now it's gathering more
information.  Then then I'll
And then I'll do
some snuff the app like
do some
stuff in the app and now I'll
stop recording.
So now the timeline is showing
me here that during this inter
interval we had more
information and I can stop, I
can click on a particular thread
so the thread display there's
there's the middle and
you can see that three looks
interesting.  I'm click on that.
You can see a flame chart on
the bottom.  This is based on --
I can narrow my focus on what
I'm particularly interested in.
We also have a -- this is the
flame chart.  And we have top
down and bottom up displays s of
the frames.  Here I can sort in
descending order of method
calls, , for example.  There's
.  That's the CPU
profileer.  Last but not     not
least we have the network
the network
profiler.  I think I was told
about five mega bytes per hour
is what this cost.  Now I'm
going to go live and we are are
going to look at memory.  I'm
going to go inside the
to go inside
the app and skit to clear
and skit to
clear all
and skit to clear
and skit          and ask
it to clear all of its cashes
its catches
its caches s.  This is
showing you the memory of the
app right noup.  And let's start
collecting allocation stack
choice.  This means any type of
allocation in the app is going
to record where it's done.   .
Now I'm going to do more memory
intensive activities.  You can
see in the background the
metrics are scrolling as its
realizing the heap is larger.
Now let's go in and grab a heap
dump here.  So now it's fetching
a heech         a heap dump.
And that should be
should be fast.  So here
here we can see basically a
summary of the objects s in the
heap.  If I click on for example
the bit map there's 76
there's 76 bit maps, I
can see those objects s.  I can
click on a bit map class.  I
can now start chasing down the
references if I want to look for
a leak.  I can also see which
bit map is this.  Or if this was
allocated during my allocation
tracking run I can see the
allocation stack choice where
this came from.  And for other
classes for example string we
show the actual string.  That's
the new profiler.  We hope it
makes your apps better.
(Applause).
over to Xav who is going to show
you how we make your builds
perform faster.
» XAVIER DUCROHET:  Thank you.
» XAVIER DUCROHET:  Let's start
with a story.  Finally the URL
is made on Google droth
on Google.com.
.  You can use the Google
shock so it's much easier.  You
don't have to remember the URL.
We are publishing all the super
libraries through the story and
we have applauded all the
triggers s version of the sue
better lie greater
library.  You can start using
it.  We know it's a big
it's a big problem
for developers   ers.  We spent
the last few quarters folks
focusing
focusing on that.  We looked at
the bigger ones that take the
longest to run and looked at
what we can do to make them
incremental.  As of 3.5 it's by
default.  It doesn't
.  It's something we are
working with to fix.  Decks
xing
Dexing works with -- that will
make a big difference.  Finally
APK packaging in 2.2 we have
incremental paneling
paneling          panelingic
paneling
paneling          packages.  We
made a lot of progress for the
final 3.0.  And if you're using
shrinking in order
ing, we have an incremental sh
rinker so you can use that just
for debug.
So the second thing I want to
talk about is the build cache.
Greater in 3.5 released
released build cache that works
at the task level so it looks
at the hash of all your inputs s
and now it can use that cache
as a key in the cache
of all your inputs and now it
can use that cache as a key in
the cache.  It's going to get
the output from the cache rather
than rerun the cache so it
should be           should be
faster.
There's a different version of
the cache, the first one is
local.  So it's good when you're
switching between branches
and then      then the other
one is the distributed one share
with team mates and build
server.  They have a limitation
that you can use, , gradle
enterprise.  And a API
for your back end.
We are planning to role out more
of those and most of them by
the time 3.0 is final so that
should make a big improvement.
Another thing is how should I
organize            I organize
my project?  How many modules?
So generally more modules mean
you can go around
increment in some of the tasks
s.  If you want to have better
control of API and dependcies,
your business logic should
probably not have -- with
cacheing in particular having
more modules means having more
to a cache and that's better.
In
.  There's a talk today at 5:30
talking about
talking about building up speed
and they will talk about that at
that point.
While I'm adding more modules
and my build is smaller, what
gives?  This is really what we
focused on in 3.0.  The first
thing we looked at was the
startup cost.  The configuration
time that happens every time
you want to do build or sync.
We have a project from a develop
er, about twon      135 modules
modules and it took
almost 200 to configure.  We
figuresd d that      d that
We fixed that
but there are still things we
shouldn't           shouldn't be
doing and we couldn't
couldn't really fix it properly
without a lot of the new APIs s.
In
3.0 we finally fixed that.
There's still room for
improvement but we will do that
later.  The other thing we
looked at was bottle neck when
you have a lot of modules.  It's
something we worked closely
with the team and finally we can
fix that.  Let's look at an
example here.  Here on the left
we have tasks that belong to an
app that consumes a library and
a task on the right.  Let's go
through what happened in the
build and we are going to
basically build all the elements
s of the app of the library and
package them and unzip that
that AAR and consume it on
the app.  Again with those new
APIs s we that have we can
public lush all
can publish all
those elements s and the build
can look something like that.
As soon as it's slabl
as it's available
as it's
available we can keep building
the library but you can start
billing the app
you can start
building the app, too
.  All right.  Let's talk about
new build features.  I want to
mention that it's just the first
day.  We are not staying
not saying it's
going to fix everything.  It's
just like a first stepped.  Some
new build features.  First is
Java         is Java
eight language features
.  All you have to set up is the
source compatibility and the
target compatibility.  The build
looks something like this.  We
go from Java C to convert that
to Java seven byte      byte
code and transform that and to
dexing.  Just as a heads up
later in 3.1 we are going to do
those steps and do the transform
after.  The second feature I
want to talk about is dependency
management.  There's a lot of
changes here in 3.0.  If you
have an app and a library right
now the library or the app only
consumed d the latest version of
the library.  So on the right
you have the configuration of
the library and then you have
the configuration of the app,
debug, release and compile
packaging.  You can go through
that manually but it doesn't
doesn't quite work very
well.  In 3.0 things are more
more xil indicated, what
complicated             more
complicated.  We have debug
element and untime element.  We
finally fixed that in 3.0 and
now the step goes auto
automatically where you don't
have to try to make that work.
Let's see how it works.
Basically we have the ability to
set up attributes on the
configuration object.  We
created an attribute and debug
matches debug and release
matches release.  If you have
flavor, the big matches the
flavor.  Now of course if you
don't have the same number of
flavor everywhere it going to
work like if you don't have them
in the library, blue debig is
going to match with debug
automatically
automatically.  If you have a
library with flavors s but you
don't ever a flavor in the
application you have to fix it.
It's called flavor selection.
We are going do that where you
tell the build I want to pick
blue instead of orange and then
it just works.
Now if you switch to 3.0 and you
have              and you have
flavors s you're likely to run
into that error of saying flavor
dimension is not required but
not if you have a singular
dimension.  Fixing it is very
easy.  You have your code and
you fix it with that.  You don't
need to put it in flavor one or
flavor two block because
there's only one dimension.  We
fix that for you.  The big
question is why can't we just
just pick up the random
default value?  Let's go through
an example.   .  Here we have
an app        an app and it
requires debug orange.  We have
a library, one with two flavors
flavors, and you can
see that's not the same orange.
When the app says orange it's
like I don't know which orange
you want.  So that's why we ask
you to name those dimensions
because we are going to use that
as the name of the attribute.
And name of the attribute is
color blue, color orange, fruit
straw       strawberry and we
can make the right collection
the right
selection.  You have flavor
flavor selection and you
need to not just give us plu
us blue but color blue and
then it works out of the box.
Okay.  Let's talk about instant
apps.  Let's say you have
an app that the application
module, some library module and
you want to make some of these
libraries as features for your
instant app.  The first thing
you're going to do is change
some of these plugins s to be
not library but the feature.
And what is nice about that
feature plug in is that it uses
the     s the attribute that
somebody just talked about so
that it publishes both
an AR and a feature APK.  When
an app says hey I depend on you,
give me your artifact, it adds
saying I'm an app and it going
to link to it the right
configuration and consume the
feature plug in or as an AR.
When you have another module
that is an instant app and the
goal of that instant app is not
to build anything, it's just to
package, to grab all of the
feature APK then the feature
plug in will build a feature APK
something that you can
distribute to your phone.  And
that's where you can really
share code without having
to do some weird search, just
change the flug          the
plug in and that's it.  If you
want more information about
Android plugs there's a talk at
3:30 today.  With that, back to
Jamal.
(Applause).
» JAMAL EASON:  All right.  So
now you've developed and built
your application.  Now it's time
to test.  So we offer a new
Android emulateor which released
about a year half ago
a year and a half ago.
After launching we talked about
two pain points for developers
ers.  They want to try out
their end to end flow.  What
does the experience look like
when my user download my app.
Or what is the experience of an
in-app purchase?  The second was
around Gap     Google+
Google Play services.  We added
the Google Play store to the
emulator.
(Applause)
frf    .
Now this small step was a lot of
work.  There was a lot of
quality and performance
enhancements s.  Along with that
we also added support for open
GL,
ES 3.0.  And lastly we    we we
added proxy support
.  I want to talk         to
talk about the impact and
applications s of the Play Store
.  There's access to the
operating system and your app by
everything elevator privileges.
By adding the Google Play
store we have a new edition
called the Google Play he had
dation              edition.  If
you want Google Play and Google
APIs s just use the Google Play
edition.  If you want the deep
access and root access you still
have the edition that's still
available.  There's a new app
bug reporting system.  We heard
from some people like I want a
quick way to have a bug report.
Noi      .  Now with 1 or 2
clicks        clicks you can
create a bug report, do a repo
step.  It should make it quicker
for user development.
Lastly for those of how do
Android Wear development, as you
heard with Android ware
Android Wear we
added a feature to test that all
inside the            inside
the Android emulator.  Lastly
about debugging is the layout in
inspector.  We have a rich
new layout editor which allows s
you to do new things with your
application.  Many times
.  We went into
layout inspector last year to
help debug your layouts s for
Android app.  Lastly optimize.
So as you heard during the
keynote we talked about Android
vitals, what this really is
about is the system health of
your phone and the apps on it.
The way you think about this is
akin to information that's
available.  As you get system
health information now available
through the Google Play console
or Firebase now you have a list
of systems s of
of symptoms s of what might be
might be going on with
your application.  There's a
deeper understanding of what is
going on.  As Tor showed you
this is the Android profiler.  I
hope you take advantage of all
these various tools to
understand what is going on with
the CPU, the memory usage to
the memory, and lastly the
network profiler.
The last topic I want to talk
about is around APK size.  So as
you heard on the keynote
yesterday we announced Android
go            Android go.  Many
times your APK you might have
legacy code or things going out
that you don't remember puting
into the app.  We have now added
additional capable to the APK
analyzer
.  As demonstrated we added
support, better byte code
support and much more.
And lastly I want to call out a
big feature around vector assets
.  I'm a big fanned        fan
of using vector assets.  We
added WebP support.  You can
save upwards of 25% in your file
size which is a huge savings
for APK.  If you right
right click it will auto convert
it to webP and you can convert
it back.  With that, that's
Android studio.  So we talked
about a range of features from
develop, adding support, better
support into the guild system
and
a whole suite of opzation tools
of
optimization tools for you.
With that, that's our talk.
Thank you so much.
(Applause)
system and a whole suite of
optimization tools for you.
With that, that's our talk.
Thank you so much.
(Applause).
(Session concluded)
.
Twesm           .
12:30 p.m.
What's new in Google Play at I/O
I/O 2017.
(Standing pie)      by).
(Music)
.
Eye.
(Applause)
.
(Applause).
» Wow, that was fun, wasn't
wasn't it?  Good afternoon.
Hello.  Hello, everyone.  All
right.  I'm Purnima
I'm Purnima Kochikar and my team
has the privilege of working
with apps and games developers
ers globally.  The animation
you just saw is inspired by the
amazing content you create which
gives people super powers s and
helps us move the mobile
ecosystem forward.
Thank you.
Before we jump into what is new
on Google Play, let's take a
moment to look back at the
amazing growth we have seen
since we met at I/O     I/O a
year ago.  You heard at the
keynote that Android and Play
are being used by increasing
number of users around the world
and there is now active on 2
billion devices         devices
monthly, and an astounding 80
billion apps
billion apps have been installed
from Google Play in the last 12
months.
This is translating into more
developers   ers finding success
on Google Play.  In the last
year alone, the number of
developers   ers with more than
1 million installs
installs grew by 35%.  This is
phenomenal.  And makes me truly
happy.  Give yourselves a very
big hand.
(Applause)
.
We are are also investing to
enable everyone to pay for your
apps and games using forms of
payment that they prefer.  For
example, Americans s prefer
credit cards, Japanese prefer D
DCB     DCB, Germans s prefer
pay     PayPal.   .  The sheer
scale of a payment platform that
you see behind me continues s
to amaze me.  As a result we are
seeing that increased number of
people paying for your apps and
games than ever before.  In the
last year alone, the number of
new buyers on Play grew by 30%.
In particular, we are seeing
great traction for the sub
strappings
for the
subscription
subscription business model.  62
62 percent of
percent of the subscribers s
telling us they use their app at
least once a day.  Beyond
payments are he always in
also      also invest
ing in capables s to help you
reach users in new way
ilities
to help you reach users in new
way.  Last year in I/O     I/O
we previewed Android instant
apps.  This allows s users to
get access to your app without
the hurdle of having to install
the app.  We are grateful to
many of you I can see you in the
audience here to worked us
here to worked
with us to make that vision a
reality.  Today we open our
instant apps to everyone.  I
hope you'll all start working on
them.
yesterday we previewed Android
go    go which is an optimized d
version of Android for imaging
marketing devices.  As you know
there are billions of people in
images        imaging market
whose are coming on to mobile
for the first time.  Please take
the time to look at the
building for billions guidelines
to help you gild          you
build for these sdweess
for these
devices s.  Above all, we are
taking into account quality in
every decision we are making on
the Play Store.  Through
programs like early access, we
are bringing you dedicated and
highly motivated 23 million plus
people who are willing to test
your apps and give you feedback
while they're still in
development before you put it up
for production.  We are
engaging
with      with Indies around
the world to find the best
quality games and on the Indie
corner.  And we are also taking
into account engage nent
engagement in all
that shape or          shape our
top charts.  And today this
evening we will host the second
annual Google Play awards
.  We will be celebrating the
best of the best, acknowledging
great quality in apps and games.
I hope to see you there.
Please come.  Be inspired d.
And come to celebrate what makes
great apps and games.
So, just as your apps are giving
people super powers s, our
engineering and product teams
are working on capabilitys to
give you the super powers s to
succeed on Google Play.
So are you ready to see what
they have been cooking?
You can do better than that.  A
ll right.  Put your hands
together for Matt Henderson,
group product manager.
(Applause).
» MATT HENDERSON:  All right.
Thanks, Purnima.  Hi, everyone
.  In your organizations who
else besides you cares about the
success of your app?  Who else
contributes s to the success of
your app?  A lot of people,
right?  And a variety of roles
s.
Have a think about who else in
your organization should be
should be using the
Play console.  When we    we
started the console five years
ago, it was a means to get an
app from A to B #679
A to B.  From developer to the
phone.  But over the years it's
been much more than that.  With
a variety of users and a variety
of features the Play console is
playing a much broader role in
the success of your app.  With
more features the user base has
broadens          broadened to
different roles in your
organizations.  Our users now
are product managers, marketing
managers, test engineers s and
of course they're Android
developers.
So think about who else in your
organization should be
should be using the Play
console.  Now with that growth
in the variety of features UI
design needs to keep things
organized so in addition to
talking about features today I
wanted to             I wanted
to touch on the UI look and feel
of the console.  You may have
noticed some changes.  We have
launched a new cleaner and
clearer material design based
play console.  And it has a new
name.  The play developer
console is now just the play
console.  This reflects s the
fact that although all of your
organizations develop apps,
knots all of              , not
all of you are developers   ers.
The user base is    is getting
more and more diverse and we
are playing a more diverse role
in the success of your app.
Early feedback about the UI
suggests we are on the right
track such as this from the E
commerce
app Zalando.
It's more intuitive, more
structured d, more convenient.
But of course in addition to a
new design we are being hard at
work with new functionality.  So
here are some highlights s of
launches from the past 12 months
months.  There's been
features to help app quality
like beta testing and the pre
launch report.  There's new
tools to manage the release
process.  There's also new
reporting and pricing features
to help you identify and take
advantage of opportunities to
grow your business.  And now at
this I/O     I/O we are
announcing important new and
updated features in all of these
areas that go even further at
helping you create high quality
app experiences but go even
further at helping you might
gate risk in
you mitigate risk and help
you go further into
go further in
achieving business success.  I'm
going to hand you over to more
of the team to give you a
snapshot of each of these
different features.  Starting
with Fergus from the player
team in London.
to know the see kwet
the secret to
getting a five star app on
Google Play?  We fund         We
found that 50% of all the one
star reviews are talking about
stability issues so if you want
to increase your star rating and
reduce the number of one star
ratings, the number one thing
you can do is focus on stability
of your application.  Okay.
Once you fix those stability
issue what's do you
issues what
do you do to increase it to
five stars       stars?  Well
you focus on design, usability
and speed.
Yesterday in the keynote you
might have seen Android vitals
s.  This is our initiative at
Google to help you understand
the performance and stability of
your applications s.  We had
hundreds of millions s of users
who opted in to share their
device diagnostics s with Google
so we can help partners s like
you to have better experiences
.  We are starting with three
perform mabs
three performance areas,
stability, battery and rendering
.  We are going to be expanding
to many more over the course of
the next year so stay tuned for
those.  As we expand there's a
lot of data to understand.  How
do we simplify it for you?  We
are chooseing this concept of
bad behaviors.  It's when your
app falls within the lowest 25%
of appears            % of apps
for that metrics and you'll be
able to understand
to understand that you should
prioritize fixing your app in
that area.  The first area is
stability.  This is all about
providing a robust and stable
experience to your users that is
reliability                is
reliable.  There are two
performance metrics within this
area.  The first is your AN
ANR rate, application not
responding rate.  This      This
is when your app freezes for
more than five seconds.  Second
is crash rate.  The second
performance area is battery.
This is where your app is using
the radios s or the CPU
unnecessarily.  And the two
performance metrics that
that were focused on here are
stuck wake lock, it's where you
hold a wake locks for more than
an hour when it's supposed to
be idle.  The second is wake ups
s.  The perj performance area
is rendering.  So this is
providing users with
area is rendering.  So this is
providing users with that
significant
that silky smooth        smooth
experience on your device so
it's clear and fluid.  There's
slow rendering, it's when 50% of
your frames take more than 60
milliseconds                 60
milliseconds.  And the second
one     one is frozen frames.
This is where 0.    0.1% of your
frames take more than seven
hundred milliseconds
milliseconds to render.  Both of
these are shown in the Play
developer console alongside all
the other five behaviors
behaviors that I
mentioned.  You can go to the
play developer console as of
right now and see this data for
your application and then you
can be able to focus on
improving their core metrics.
For each one we provide links to
develop
er.Android          er.Android
.com.  Finally if you don't care
about your star rating which
I'm sure most of you do, we also
have other reasons why you
should care      care about this
performance area.  We are
starting to it use in the
promoteability in the store
itself and other things we are
going to talk about later on
today at 5:30 in a talk on the
top ten things        things to
improve the stability of your
application.  You can be able to
learn more about how we are
improving the Play Store to be
able to use this performance
data.  I'll talk about the field
data and welcome Ricardo on
stage who is going to talk about
how you can understand the
performance of your application
before you launch it.
(Applause).
» Rick cardo            Ricardo:
Thank you.  Hi, everyone,
great to be here today.  Today I
want to talk
to you about the prelaunch
report.  The prelaunch report
summarizes s issues when testing
against a wide range of devices
s.  Prelunch          Prelaunch
report contributes
s to better ops.  The key aspect
of prelaunch report is app
stability testing.  We
automatically test alpha or beta
channels s in the Play console
against several physical
physical Android
diseases s.
Android devices s.  You can fix
the crash before it reaches
production and your users will
not leave a one star review
because of that.  In the last
year prelaunch rarpt
launch report has seen great
multipleum.
great momentum
.  In 85    85% of the cases
when prelaunch report found a
crash the app was not later push
pushed to production which
means that millions s of users
have not experienced crashs that
would have otherwise affected
them      them which is pretty
nice.
So we continue to improv pre
launch report to make it even
better
report to make it even better.
It can now provide test
credentials s.  Prelaunch
report using if knowledge of
Google's own security teams.
Now we detect over 30 different
types of vulnerabilities and
privacy issues from using
obsolete libraries to known
identifiers s.  Pre
s.  We now take into
account the structure of your
app such as activity and
transition to better capture
screen shots intelligently and
this gives you a better view at
a glance which is great for
spotting visual inconsistencies.
the most.  We added new devices
to                new devices to
the floor including the Google
pixel run on Android O preview
much                O preview.
.  You can check Android O and
be ready for when it launches
later this year.  You can upload
an APK right now to the Play
console and there's a good
chance that by the end of this
talk you'll get a sense of how
your app performs s on snoid
s on Android O.
That's all I have for you today.
I have the prelaunch report
report with that sense
of security and I will like to
introduce James Smith, project
manager on play.  Thank you.
(Applause).
» James Smith:  Thanks, Rick
yard           Ricardo.  Hi
everyone.  One of the        of
the most important things you
have to             you have to
look after is your app sign-in
key because your app sign-in key
ensures s the integrity of your
app.  Your private key is
required for signing all
versions of your app.  If you
lose or misplace your key, you
will not be able to publish
updates to your app.  Your only
option would be to publish a new
app under a new package name
and ask all of your users to
move across.  This would be
obviously a terrible experience.
So that's why we are very
excited to be launching Google
Play app signing.
(Applause).
If you join this program Google+
program Google
Play will manage your key on
your behalf and sign your app
before delivering it to years
to users.  First you
securely upload your app sign-in
key to Google Play.  That means
it's now safe on Google
on Google servers s
and you don't need to worry
about security and access to
your key.  You can even delete
it.  To make sure that updates
to your app come from you, the
authorized d developer, any new
APKs s you upload will be
will be signed with an
upload key that Google uses to
verify your identity.  The
upload key with          key can
be re-set.  We have had several
partners s using Google Play
app signing for pay while and
the feedback has been positive
a
while and the feedback has been
positive
.  Now, once Google Play signs
your app, we can go one step
further and we can provide
optimization services at your
request.  The first optimization
we have decided to
decided to focus on is making
apps smaller.  We know that
developers   ers care about app
size because users do.  APK size
is correlated d with download
success and with uninstall rate.
that developers   ers include
native libraries and different
architectures s and draw ables
drawables s so that
apps look and run their best on
every device.  But this means
that a lot of the contents s of
an APK is unnecessary
unnecessary for
every device.  If I have a phone
with a 32 bit architecture and
and     and screen then I
only need the contents s in blue
.  With app optimizations s
playable delivered just the
right content for each device.
You give us a universe
a universal APK and
we will create optimized d APKs
s for different devices.
exploreing this area and     and
it's still early but we tried
it with app there's
there's the early access prop
and we sfekt the average signing
we
expect the average signing to
be about 15%.  Deliveroo was 33%
smaller and the seven minute
workout was nearly half smaller
at 48%.  So when can you get
these benefits?  Well
, app signing is available today
.  We hope to widen the beta in
the near future f you're
interested in optimizations s
please enroll in app signing
today.  If you would like to
nind         to find out more
about these topics s please come
to our talk at    at 2:30 this
afternoon                this
afternoon.  I had like to invite
Mike to talking about device
catalog which is also available
today.
(Applause).
» Mike
:  Thanks, James.  So, as we saw
at the start of this talk the
Android he can seesm
ecosystem is    is
seeing significant grout
significant
growth and this is in part due
to the diversity of Android
devices s with a range of
different capabilities and price
points.  We hear that you love
the reach this brings but
understanding this device space
and targeting the right devices
s can sometimes be a bit of a
challenge.  And so to help with
this, we have launched a new
device catalog section in the
Google Play console.  Thank you.
(Applause).
Using everything that we know
about Android we have gone from
this long list of device codes
to a rich full featured d device
catalog.  Looks pretty awesome,
right?  So what can this do for
you?  First of all, we provide
detailed device specks including
RAM, system on chip, GPU, scre
en size and OS version for every
one of the thousands of Android
devices s certified by Google.
We group them into models s to
understand the variations
between them.  To help navigate
this device space we provide
search and filter options allow
ing to you slice and     and
dice the cat         the catalog
.  For example you can use this
to quickly find all SD    SDK
level 24 devices with a snap
dragon 8-10 sock.  All devices s
manufactured by Google with
more than two giga ram.  This is
more than just device specks w
any     any       w
specks        specks.  With any
filter we provide key metrics
for how your app performs on
these devices s such as installs
s and revenue.  In addition to
this we introduced another new
feature             new feature
called device exclusion rules.
This allows you to exclude your
app from a specific targeted set
of devices s use key device
performance indicators s.  For
example if you're developing a
rich graphics s game you could
use this to only target devices
s with more than a gig of ram.
You could also create a rule to
exclude all devices s with a
particular system on chip.  This
can allow you to temporarily
prevent deployment of your app
to a specific set of problematic
devices until you can push a
fix.
When ever you create an
exclusion rule we would always
show you which devices will be
s will be excluded d.
Along with installs and revenue
metrics to help you make this
important decision with
confidence.
along with installs and revenue
metrics to help you make this
important decision with
confidence.
As you can see games have found
a great way of incore
incorporateing device tools.  To
hear more about this new device
catalog feature along with
other release management tools
you can check out the recording
of this talk that was presented
yesterday.  Also please swing by
the Play con              the
Play console sandbags
sandbox area where we are
available to give demos s,
answer questions and give
feedback.  And with that I'm
going to hand you over to
Suzanne to tell us about even
more new ways we have to release
with conversation.
(Applause)
with
confidence.
(Applause).
» Suzanne:  Thank you.  Thanks,
Mike.  I'll walk you through
through the release
dashboard which we announced
yesterday.  You want to make
sure that your production
release is successful.  We have
always been ahead of the curve
to prepare great releases.
Think about the prelaunch report
and our afl         our alpha
and beta channels s.  Out of the
box without a need for an SD
for an SDK.  This
data is offered in low latency
and can help you     you make
decisions about your role out
sooner and with more confidence.
Let me shoal you
me show you a few highlights s.
When you push a new release you
care about crashes.  We give
you absolute numbers s as well
as crashes for a thousand
devices s to put those numbers
in context.  The default shown
here offers a comparison between
your current release and the
aggregate of all app versions
that you have in production
.  Releases aren't all about
crashes.  You also      also
want to see ratings and reviews
s that are specific to your
latest version         version.
When a rating for your latest
version is lower than that of
your overall rating you may want
to start looking in to your 1
and 2 star reviews to see what
is going on and possibly hold
your release.
What if you could
see install         install
events s broken down by new
installs s and updates s.  This
s.  Think about the
power of knowing how much
uninstalls s came from updated
devices s.
Are you losing existing
customers because your latest
version isn't       isn't
performing well?  Clay has these
numbers
Clay       ?  Play has these
numbers s for you out of the box
.  I encourage you to think
about what makes a healthy
release.  Your crash tool may
warn you if you have a huge
spike.  What about subtle but
significant changes across
metrics?  Would you ever notice
if you didn't see them all in
one place?  And to empower your
decision making even further we
also let you compare your
release against the previous
release of your choice.  This
gives you even more context.
You don't only have fewer
crashes and AN    ANR's, you
you don't only have the impact
of your en installs
your uninstalls s but you
can see how they're considered
successful, all in one place
within hours of release starting
.  So next time you roll a new
version out, monitor it with the
release dashboard.  It is the
new item on the release
management.  Now over to Preston
, engineering manager, to talk
you through new statistics s
pages.  Thank you.
(Applause).
» Preston:  Thanks, Suzanne.  Hi
, everyone.  We have been hard
at work this year addressing
your the     the requests in
play stfshgs              play
statistics s.  Lied        s.  I
had like to introduce the new
Play statistics s page.  You can
start to feel the magnitude
that we put behind the statics s
brand since the last I/O
I/O.  First let's drill down in
to date selection.  As you can
see we still have the pre-set
date ranges but these pre-sets
are not     not sufficient for
all business needs       needs
so I'm happy to say we added a
custom date range selection to
help you choose the date range
you're most interested in.  We
know many of you manually
compare data in the console with
data from previous time periods
.  We made that much simpler by
plotting a comparison time
period right alongside your date
range.  This allows you to see
trends that will highlight the
impact of releases, marketing
campaigns s and even public
holidays.
But time periods amp
periods aren't the only thing
we want to compare.  Now on the
Play statistics s page you can
select multiple metrics to
compare at the same time.  When
you can easily compare related
metrics such as crashes in
ratings you can start to uncover
relationships in your data that
are are specific to your app
and to your market.  The last
thing I would like to mention is
is hourly data.  We are
introducing new hourly stats to
help you understand the behavior
of your app throughout the day.
This knowledge will hoe you as
you plan time sensitive events
s such as releases.  You want to
have wait until tomorrow to
start to see data
you as you plan time sensitive
events such as releases.  You
want to have wait until tomorrow
to start to see data for today.
We made      made Play
statistics s more useful to help
you build apps.   .  I'd invite
to you come to the sandbox to
talk about more w that I'll hand
it over
to Tamzin to talk about
acquisition.
Nauz
(Applause).
»Tamzin:   Thank you.  So once
you're confident that your apps
health and performance is
optimal you probably want to
drive new valuable users to your
app, right?  Well, in my job I
talk to developers   ers every
day and they tell me how
critical it is to understand how
effective their marketing
channels are at acquiring and
retaining new valuable users.
They tell me they need more data
to make the right decision
about where to spend their money
and where to spend their time
and effort in optimizing their
growth strategies.  Since last
I/O     I/O we launched two
improvement
improvements to the user
acquisition report to make this
area of the console even more
useful for you.
Now just      just to remind you
the user acquisition report
shows you how much user
s go to your            s go to
your install listing page, how
many install your app, and how
many buy and buy again.  So the
first improvement was we added
country to the user acquisition
traffic break down.  This is
really critical because we want
you to expand and succeed and
reach those 2 billion monthly
active Android devices around
the world.
Now this report is great because
it will show you where the
unrealized opportunities so that
you can prioritize your
international expansion.
The second improvement is that
we'll added peer benchmarks.
Now this let's you see how your
app conversion compares to
similar apps in the same
category.  Now this is available
both in the acquisition report
and in the country report.  So
it let's you see obvious areas
for improvement, it let's you
see areas to further invest to
acquisition, and let's you
celebrate your team success.
Now I'm pretty            I'm
pretty confident that most of
you here care about building
long-term customer relationships
, right?  So today I'm really
excited to            excited to
announce version two of the
funnel.  Especially for
businesses like yours who have a
strong focus on user retention.
It shows retention periods
which are critical metrics for
understanding which channels are
bringing you your most loyal
users.  And this is your
retained installer base.  It
shows you the opportunity to
country retention using
notifications and e-mail or
increasing your app quality.  So
from today you'll be able to
identify which channels s I'm
bringing you your most      most
valuable users, which countries
they're coming from and you'll
be able to identify the
opportunities you had to
increase your install and buy
conversion and increase your
user retention.  All of these
reports help you optimize growth
strategies not just for
installs s but for long-term
business success.  So regardless
of the way you monetize we have
an acquisition report that can
help you grow your business.  If
you want to learn more about
this or the release dashboard or
the new stafshgs s page
statistics s page you
should            you should
come to stage one at 1:30 right
after this.  So come and see us.
page you should come to stage
one at 1:30 right after this.
So come and see us.  Now I would
like to welcome back
on stage Fergus..
(Applause)
» Fergus:   Great so I'm back
again to help those people who
who had their hand up
earlier about trying to get a
five star rating on Play.
There's improvements s we made
and we just announced.  One
thing we announced at Google I/O
I/O last year was reviews
analysis.  This enables s you to
be able to see the topics that
people are talking about in your
reviews s on Google Play and
prioritize which topics are
having the largest negative and
positive impact on your rateing
in the store.  You've heard from
developers   ers they are using
this to prior to ties
to prioritize
their feature development.  You
can understand what people in
geographys that have your app
available in but don't speak
your language are saying about
your application.  The second
most popular language on Play is
Spanish.  As of yesterday we
have sfan initials
have Spanish topics s.  We
also support Japanese topics s.
We are putting Google's
machine learning to you so we
can understand your users and
what they're saying.  A
limitation on Google Play has
been when users update        s
update their reviews s you're
only able to see the latest
update of the review.  Now you
can see the full history.  This
enables s you to have a fluid
conversation with your users and
communicate with them
effectively.
So once you start engaging with
your users and start responding
to               responding to
reviews s, how do you understand
if it's working for you?  We
have updated rating section.
This is where we show you what
is the change in rating for
reviews s you have responded to
versus ones you haven't
responded to.  We see that
developers are seeing major
results in improving their star
rating of the app by engaging
with users because they
they update their rateing to a
positive rating as a result of
engaging with them.
Finally another improvement we
are makeing to the reviews s
area is the ability to be able
to flag reviews s that have
passed through our first level
of flagging that we do
internally of reviews s where if
you think that one of the
reviews s that is posted on your
app does not match our posting
guidelines and is being filtered
through you can flag it and we
will do another manual review
check and evaluation of that
review to be able to determine
if it matches our posting
guidelines.  If it doesn't
doesn't, we will remove
that.  This is already being
rolled out to a percentage of
play developers   ers and will
be rolled out to the rest of all
developers   ers over the next
couple months.  If you want to
learn more about the secret
the secrets s to get
a higher rated app on play and
increase your usere       user
user retention come to the
talk later at 5:30.  I'd like
to wk       to welcome Tom who
is a product manager to come on
stage and talk about
subscriptions.
Nauz
(Applause).
» Tom.  Good afternoon, everyone
.  I'm sewer excited to be here.
So jets
here.  So let's          So
let's imagine you've used all
the great tools from this
I/O     I/O.  How do you
monetize them?  We think one of
the best ways to do that is to
use subscriptions on Google Play
.  One of the reasons we think
that is because subscriptions
are growing fastly.  We heard
from Purnima early on that the
number of active subscribers s
on Play has doubled.  That's
great.  Consumers spend on
subscriptions on Play has gone
up ten times in the last three
years.  That's an amazing
opportunity for developers   ers
like you to make more money,
more regularly, and more relinl
reliable y.  I'm going
to go out on a limb and say that
probably sounds pretty good to
quite a            to quite a
lot of you.  And quite a
quite a lot of us at Google
have been trying to help you.
Have been really working to
power your sub     subscription
businesses.  So today I'm going
to share a few of the new
features that we are launching
at I/O     I/O this year.  These
are features to help you guys.
Now we know that to run a
successful subscription business
you need really good data.  So
I'm really happy to say earlier
this week we launched a brand
new part of a Play con sole
a Play console, the
subscriptions dashboard.  This
pulls together key metrics s and
information and puts it's all
in one place.  At a glance you
can see your total number of
subscriptions, your new act
new activations s and
cancelations s, your daily
revenue and even your top
performing subs.  This is    is
a great way to get a look at
what you're doing.  When you
you identify an and nolly
you're                     an
anomaly you're going to want to
know more.  We are launching
three brand nucleic-
new click-through reports.  The
acquisition report, the
retention report and the churn,
the cancellation report.  Let's
look at them quickly.
The acquisition report builds on
the wonderful funnelss
ss that Tamzin showed earlier.
Now it's especially tailored for
your business.  You'll see
which drive the largest number
of free trialists s and which
eventually drive the largest
number of high value, repeat
paying subscribers s.  If you
care about putting your money
and effort into the channels
that give you the highest value
in subscriptions, this is the
report for you.  Secondly,
there's retention report.  This
powerful new report allows s to
you compare different cohorts
from different subscriptions.
So if you've got a brand new sub
that you're experimenting with
and you want to see if it
outperforms s others, you can
quick and easily plot it and
make that decision to make it a
primary one that you sell.  Or
if you try to use some of our
and advance features like
introductory pricing for
instance you can see the impact
it has.  This is a good place to
inform your product decisions
to increase your retention.
And lastly there's the churn
report.  So let's          So
let's be honest.  When someone
cancels s your subscription it
sucks.  But this report rocks.
And the reason I love this
report is because for the first
time on the Play con sole
on the Play
console you can see the exact
days that people choose to
cancel your subscriptions.  This
means you can start seeing the
impact of that release that you
made to try to lower your
your cancellation rate or you
can use it to start building a
business model behind that
feature that you think is being
to keep people around for longer
.  Taken together these three
reports         reports and the
dashboard give you a view in
your business that you've never
been able to have on the Play
console before but we know that
the insights s you derive from
these are only the beginning of
the story because those insights
s drive your decisions and
those decisions drive what tools
you choose to use.  So I'm also
happy to say this I/O     I/O
we are announcing a brand new
tool.  This will allow you to
know when a user's payment has
failed which is one of the
leading causes of    of
subscription cancellation.  It
will allow               You can
say hey there's been a problem
with your payments, go into Play
and fix it.  The user will have
30 days to fix their payment
failure.  We have been working
and trying this feature out and
we have seen a 25% increase in
retention rates.
So I account hold and new
subscription
new subscription dashboard are
two of the many features
hold and new subscription
dashboard are two of the many
features that teams are creating
to help you build successful
businesses.  If you want to know
more I encourage you to come to
stage one tomorrow
tomorrow at 10:30 as we delve
deeply into how to use more
money into subscriptions on
Google Play.  With that I would
like to invite Purnima and Matt
to round the session out.  Thank
you, very much.
Nauz
(Applause).
» MATT HENDERSON:  Thanks, Tom.
So much new stuff.  So in
addition to making use of the
stations please go online, you
can read much more about all of
this new stuff there.  And think
about who else in your
organization can become a user
of the Play console.
And also if you haven't already,
I do encourage you to download
the play book app.  We released
a new beta with a whole lot of
new content.  It's a great way
to stay informed of all of our
announcements s and blogs to
understand the features.
» PURNIMA KOCHIKAR:  All right.
Hopefully that whetted your
appetite to try to build amazing
apps and games.  I hope to see
you this evening at the Google
Play awards at 6:30 where we are
celebrating all the wonderful
work that has happened over the
last year.  I want to thank you
for challenging us to continue
usefully innovate for adopting
the features that we invest in,
and creating things that
actually provide super powers s
to your users.  So thank you
very much for being here.  And I
hope to see up at the Google